You know, hey, Will, good morning. How are you today? Oh, hey, Sean. Yeah, good morning. I'm good, too. I set my thermostat, even though it's winter. Oh, my God, hang on. Fucking, let me sit down for this. Okay, go ahead.
你知道，嘿，威尔，早安。你今天过得怎么样？哦，嘿，肖恩。对，早安。我也挺好的。我把温度调节器开着，尽管现在是冬天。哦，天哪，等一下。他妈的，让我为此坐下来。好吧，你继续。
I set my thermostat to put the air conditioning on because everybody in my building in New York has the heat on. So at night, I'm sleep with the air conditioning on. Isn't that kind of dumb? No, it's not dumb. I'm just trying to think of a synonym right now. Oh, you know what? It's Smartless.
我把温度调节器调到开冷气，因为我在纽约大楼里的每个人都把暖气开着。所以在晚上，我开着冷气睡觉。这不是很蠢吗？不，这不蠢。我只是在想要找一个同义词。哦，你知道吗？它是 Smartless。
Oh. Welcome to Smartless. So, Sean, Hey. Yeah, you know, now... I just, I'm just happy to be here. Shut up. Incredible.
哦。欢迎来到 Smartless。所以，肖恩，嘿。对，你知道，现在……我只是，我只是很高兴来到这里。闭嘴。太不可思议了。
This is amazing. Jason, don't talk to him like that. Hang on. Sean, shut up. Yeah. Sean, you're on Eastern Time, so he's more cups of coffee into his day than we are. Sean, he's so, he's such a... He never lets it show.
这太棒了。杰森，别那样跟他说话。等一下。肖恩，闭嘴。对。肖恩，你在东部时间，所以他比我们多喝了几杯咖啡。肖恩，他太，他太……他从来不表现出来。
He works his freaking tail off. He's there in rehearsal doing this play. And then he just, shows up and he doesn't complain. Do you ever know that? Well, live with me. Let me ask Crankerville. Crankerville, do you notice?
他拼了老命在工作。他在排练中演这出戏。然后他只是，出现却不抱怨。你知道吗？好吧，跟我住在一起。让我问问克兰克维尔。克兰克维尔，你注意到了吗？
I've never heard you complain about anything. He doesn't, right? I do. I kind of do. Well, I would... Like, it's Scottie's like, all he does is complain. Scotty's listening in that was this. So wait, so wait, is Scotty always on, always on an extra set of kids?
我从来没听你抱怨过什么。他没有，对吧？我有。我其实有点会。好吧，我会……就像斯科蒂一样，他只会抱怨。斯科蒂正在听，就是这个。所以等等，所以等等，斯科蒂是不是一直在，一直带着另一套孩子？
Not always, but a lot of times he listens, like, just for fun. I love it. Yeah. Now, Sean, you haven't, I got a full night of Willie's new look last night. Oh, right, yeah, yeah. He just looks so goddamn handsome with this facial hair. Look at that. Cut his hair.
不总是，但很多时候他会听，就像，只是为了好玩。我喜欢。对。现在，肖恩，你还没有，我昨晚看了威利的新造型。哦，对，没错，没错。他留着这个面部毛发看起来太帅了。看那个。剪了头发。
Yeah, you never grow your beard out. I know, thank you. Yeah. Wear your rings, Willie. Did you get to keep the reins? I know, I know. So for Tracy, Will's doing this big film to follow up the other film. It's for a part?
对，你从来不留胡子。我知道，谢谢。对。戴上你的戒指，威利。你留住缰绳了吗？我知道，我知道。所以对特拉西来说，威尔正在拍这部大电影来接档上一部电影。这是为了一个角色吗？
It's not for a part? Yeah. Yeah, it's for the thing I just did with Tony Gilroy. Well, say what it is. Tony Gilroy's directing. You and Pedro Pascal, and who else? And Olivia Wilde and a lot of great people. And it's, yeah, it's called Bohemoth.
不是为了一个角色吗？对。对，是为了我和托尼·吉尔罗伊刚刚做的那件事。好吧，说出那是什么。托尼·吉尔罗伊在导演。你和佩德罗·帕斯卡，还有谁？还有奥利维亚·王尔德以及很多优秀的人。它是，对，它叫《贝希摩斯》。
And, yeah. Yeah, it's very cool that you're part of that. Yeah, it was really fun. Yeah, it was really fun that they asked me to... Well, wait, are you playing some fucking stud? Because he's a... He's a... He's a...
然后，对。对，你能成为其中的一部分真的很酷。对，真的很有趣。对，他们邀请我参加真的很有趣……好吧，等等，你在演什么他妈的猛男吗？因为他是一个……他是一个……他是一个……
I can't really say anything, because I realize that they haven't said anything of what it's about, So I'm not allowed to really say. It's not Star Wars. Fucking hit cake. Please, my dad. You have like watermark scripts and stuff? Of course.
我真的不能说什么，因为我意识到他们还没有透露它是关于什么的，所以我真的不能说。这不是《星球大战》。他妈的敲蛋糕。拜托，我爸。你们有那种水印剧本之类的东西吗？当然。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, it's... Well, you're handsome in it. I can tell you that. So you're going to hold the look, you're going to keep the look. I mean, you know, listen, I mean, for anyone who cares out there, us soft actor guys, the only time we ever stumble into a new look, it's because somebody with taste in a makeup trailer kind of carved one into us,
对，对，对。我的意思是，它是……好吧，你在里面很帅。我可以告诉你这一点。所以你会保持这个造型，你会保持这个造型。我的意思是，你知道，听着，我的意思是，对于外面任何关心的人来说，我们这些温和的演员，我们偶然获得新造型的唯一时间，是因为化妆车里有品位的人为我们雕琢了一个，
for a part and then we're like, we're done with the movie and we're like, oh, maybe I'll just hold on to a little element of this. Look at me. Like when you had your long hair for a while. Well, I still, yeah, I mean, I still, Amanda, I came home, Amanda was like, oh, you're keeping that. Really? Oh, God.
为了一个角色，然后我们拍完电影就觉得，哦，也许我会保留这个的一小部分。看看我。就像你留了一段时间长发的时候。好吧，我还是，对，我的意思是，我还是，阿曼达，我回到家，阿曼达就说，哦，你要留着这个。真的吗？哦，天哪。
Yeah. Yeah, but you cut it off pretty fast after the Black Rabbit. But it's still a little long, isn't it? I mean, it's not stupid long like it was before. Remember when, like, when Jason got like really kind of in shape and he was doing Black black rabbit and he had the long hair and he was really ripped up. And Amanda was like, it's kind of, it's kind of. Amanda was like, it's kind of like having sex with like a stranger.
对。对，但你在《黑兔子》之后很快就把它剪了。但它还是有点长，不是吗？我的意思是，它不像以前那样蠢长。还记得当，就像，当杰森变得真的有点健美，他当时在拍《黑兔子》，留着长头发，真的非常健美。然后阿曼达就说，这有点，这有点。阿曼达说，这有点像和一个陌生人发生性关系。
And she said with kind of with glee. With some tweaker you give a ride to, we're right home for it. She was a little too excited about last night. We know. A little change of pace never hurts. But we missed you, Shawnee. It was the first time. I know.
而且她带着一种幸灾乐祸的语气说。和一个你顺便载一程的怪咖，我们直接开车回家。她昨晚显得有点太兴奋了。我们知道。换个节奏永远没有坏处。但我们想念你，肖尼。这是第一次。我知道。
What, did you guys get together last night? Yeah, we did Sunday dinner. Oh, man. And it was the first time in a while for me. And it was so great seeing everybody and seeing this guy. Did Carolyn go? The love of my life? No, she was...
什么，你们昨晚聚在一起了吗？对，我们吃了周日晚餐。哦，天哪。对我来说这是好久以来的第一次。看到大家，看到这家伙真是太棒了。卡洛琳去了吗？我一生的挚爱？不，她当时……
It's not working out, Sean. It's not working on. We're making news today, guys. No, no, no, no, no. We are not making news. That's not true. Something came up, and then we had... But we had Danny and Don Dees,
这行不通，肖恩。这行不通。我们今天在创造新闻，伙计们。不，不，不，不。我们没有在创造新闻。那不是真的。有些事情出现了，然后我们有……但我们有丹尼和唐·迪斯，
which was raising them. I just heard from Don, yeah, she's great. Willie Speck. Oh, man. The whole crew. Jimmy Hedge. And we saw a sweet... Sweet little maple.
他们在抚养他们。我刚听到唐的消息，对，她很棒。威利·斯佩克。哦，天哪。全班人马。吉米·海奇。我们看到了一个甜蜜的……甜蜜的小枫树。
Oh. Oh, Richard and Jenny. And Richard and Jenny. But Jennifer Aniston wasn't there, was she? Oh, you know it, girl. Yo, you know it. She was frying up some, what did we have last night? We had those burgers.
哦。哦，理查德和珍妮。还有理查德和珍妮。但詹妮弗·安妮斯顿不在那儿，对吧？哦，你懂的，女孩。哟，你懂的。她在煎一些，我们昨晚吃了什么？我们吃了那些汉堡。
By the way, how about Thoreau had sleeves last night? Yeah, well, it's cold. Yeah, it was a little cold. Jeez, man. He had sleeves, but he had two T-shirts. He had the layered T-shirts. He did. He had a Steve Bannon combo going.
顺便说一句，梭罗昨晚怎么穿着袖子？对，好吧，天冷。对，有点冷。天哪，老兄。他穿着袖子，但他穿了两件T恤。他穿了层叠的T恤。他确实穿了。他搞了个史蒂夫·班农的组合。
Oh my God, everybody was there You guys were missed You and Scotty Sorly missed Sorly missed Any way you can get a vicious stomach virus And get fired off that play I think about it all the time
哦，天哪，每个人都在那里。大家都很想念你。你和斯科蒂深深地想念。深深地想念。有没有什么办法能让你得个严重的胃肠病毒，然后被那出戏解雇。我一直在想这件事。
You know yesterday was the big big big snowstorm Massive so we had Oh so we canceled We had a cancel rehearsal So I still wanted to run Is this you guys rehearsing out in a park I mean, the gun, no, little excuse, let's take a day off. Yeah, we're doing, it's outside.
你知道昨天是大风雪，超级大风雪。所以我们有……哦，所以我们取消了。我们不得不取消排练。所以我还是想排练。这是你们在公园里排练吗？我的意思是，天哪，不，别找借口，我们休息一天吧。对，我们在做，在室外。
It's in the, it's in Central Park outside. No, I said, so it was rehearsal, because you couldn't drive or go anywhere in the streets or whatever. So anyway, so they canceled, and I said this, but I still wanted to run the show, so it's like fresh in my head, you know? So I said, Scotty, there's a performance in the bedroom tonight. It starts at 7 p.m. There's one ticket because there's one chair in the bedroom.
在外面中央公园里。不，我说，所以是排练，因为你没法开车或去街上的任何地方或者别的什么。所以无论如何，他们取消了，我说这个，但我还是想把这出戏跑一遍，这样它在我脑子里还是新鲜的，你知道吗？所以我说，斯科蒂，今晚卧室里有一场演出。晚上7点开始。只有一张票，因为卧室里只有一把椅子。
I said you can, there's a bathroom. There's no intermission, but there's a bathroom right next to the chair. And if you want to fall asleep during the performance, there's a bed. Jesus, I'm getting a heart on. Tell me more about it. What a cell. Yeah. What a cell on this play. I mean, Jesus.
我说你可以，有个洗手间。没有中场休息，但椅子旁边就有一个洗手间。如果你想在演出期间睡着，还有一张床。天哪，我都要勃起了。多跟我讲讲。真是个好卖点。对。这出戏的卖点真好。我的意思是，天哪。
How many times does that pitch come out of your mouth? There's a performance in the bedroom tonight. I was going to make a joke, but then, Sean, it occurred to me. You know what would be a great biopic you should do? Because you know a lot about it is the story of Chef Boyardee. Why not? The Chef Boyerdy story. Don't fucking threaten me.
这种推销词你嘴里说出来多少次了？今晚卧室里有一场演出。我本想开个玩笑，但后来，肖恩，我突然想到。你知道你该拍什么伟大的传记片吗？因为你对它了解很多，那就是博雅迪厨师的故事。为什么不呢？博雅迪厨师的故事。别他妈威胁我。
But how does the rehearsal for a one-man show go? What do you mean? It's just him. It's just you're up there and then the director sitting in the middle of the house. Yeah. It's just a couple. Tech is just you and it's just right? It's weird.
但独角戏的排练是怎么进行的？你是什么意思？只有他一个人。只有你站在那儿，然后导演坐在观众席中间。对。只有两个人。技术彩排就只有你，然后就是，对吧？这很怪。
But you know, the... Do you light the show with a flashlight? Is that it? Yeah, well, people have to use their phone lights. That's how we get the light. Everybody in the audience. No, they, during the run through the other day, we had our first quote audience,
但你知道，这……你用手电筒给演出打光吗？是这样吗？对，人们必须用手机的手光。我们就是这样获得光的。观众席上的每个人。不，他们在前几天的彩排中，我们有了第一个所谓的观众，
but it was all like the producers and the people, doing behind the scene stuff. So it was like 20 people, which is a lot of people who have to have been rehearsing by yourself. And so I walked in and I started laughing. I'm like, I can't do this. This is insane.
但那都是制片人和做幕后工作的人。所以大概有20个人，对于一个人自己排练来说，这已经是很多人了。所以我走进去，开始笑。我说，我做不到。这太疯狂了。
Oh, God. I all start panicking. Now, I think we talked about this before, but forgive my old man brain. I've forgotten. Do you have some sort of a net, some sort of a fail safe? Like if I go up,
哦，天哪。我都开始恐慌了。现在，我想我们以前谈过这个，但请原谅我这个老头子大脑。我忘了。你有什么安全网吗，某种万无一失的办法？比如如果我卡词了，
so somebody just off stage? Yeah, well, for previews, which are two weeks, there'll be somebody in the front row on book. Front row. You can't look to the audience for the line.
所以有人在舞台边上？对，为了预演，持续两周，第一排会有一个人拿着剧本。第一排。你不能向观众寻求台词。
No, but you can just say line or whatever. Really? And the person in the front row, like, there's going to be a person in front row with a script in their hands. This is correct. When you say a person, you mean Scotty, obviously.
不，但你可以直接说“台词”或者别的什么。真的吗？第一排的那个人，比如，第一排会有一个人手里拿着剧本。这是正确的。当你指一个人时，你显然是指斯科蒂。
Yeah. Isn't that going to be distracting for the people around this person that this person's snapping script pages? What are you going to do? I'll tell you what you're going to do. You put somebody off-stage in the wings. For the show,
对。这不会让这个人周围的人分心吗，因为这个人一直在翻剧本页？你打算怎么办？我告诉你你要怎么办。你把一个人放在舞台侧翼。对于演出，
that's something to do when we open. Don't tell them how to do. But they're selling tickets for the preview. That's correct. That's correct. I don't get that. Because they get to see how the sozy just made. It should be a discount and ticket them because Sean has never shit together yet.
那是我们开幕时要做的事。别教他们怎么做。但他们在卖预演的票。没错。没错。我不明白。因为他们能看到粗制滥造的作品是怎么诞生的。票应该打折，因为肖恩的脑子还没理清呢。
What are you at advocacy group? What are you doing? By the way, Sean, quick question. First of all, Sean, obviously Jason, I are thrilled to have you on the show. Do you, are you, shone, is... I'm such a big fan of both. We don't usually have theater types. You're so good.
你是什么维权组织吗？你在干什么？顺便问一下，肖恩，有个快问。首先，肖恩，显然杰森和我非常高兴你能来节目。你，肖恩，是……我是两人的超级粉丝。我们通常不请戏剧圈的人。你太棒了。
Do you have any stories that you like to... Shottie, do you, is Scotty offbook? Seriously? Wait, I mean, because I'm running lines with me? I mean, a tiny, not really, I mean a tiny bit. Scotty, come into frame. Scotty, are you off book over? Oh, wait, he's way down there.
你有什么想分享的故事吗……肖蒂，斯科蒂脱稿了吗？说真的？等等，我是说，因为我在跟我对词吗？我的意思是，一点点，不算真的，我的意思是微乎其微。斯科蒂，进入镜头。斯科蒂，你脱稿了吗？哦，等等，他走得太远了。
Scottie, you off book a little bit? You know that, you love that one line, I say. You know that one line. The one you always say, you nailed it. What is it? Shut up, Scotty. Just shut up. Hey, Scotty, what's the first line of the play?
斯科蒂，你稍微脱稿了吗？你知道的，你喜欢我说的那个经典台词。你知道那句台词。你总是说的那句，你抓住了精髓。是什么？闭嘴，斯科蒂。快闭嘴。嘿，斯科蒂，这出戏的第一句台词是什么？
I don't know. Oh, that's. That's your man, front row. What if the lights come up, I'm like, line. Did you get a deal on him? I told you that thing when I auditioned for David Chase for the Sopranos and I had one line and I got the Silver Cup and George Ann Walker's the casting director.
我不知道。哦，那是。那是你的人，第一排。如果灯光亮起，我说“台词”怎么办？你从他身上捡到便宜了吗？我跟你说过我为《黑道家族》去给大卫·切斯试镜的那件事，我只有一句台词，我拿到了银杯，乔安·沃克是选角导演。
I go and she goes, I know you're going to meet him, but he wants everybody to say one line. I was like, one line, how am I going to, you know, a bunch of actors out there for it? This is like 2001 or two. Anyway, I go out there. I go into the room David Chase,
我去那儿，她说，我知道你要去见他，但他希望每个人都说一句台词。我就想，一句台词，我怎么能，你知道，外面有一堆演员为了这个来？这大概是2001或2002年。无论如何，我走了出去。我走进了房间，大卫·切斯，
Jordanne Watkinson there and I've got this piece paper with the one line and she goes, you ready to start? I go yeah and he's just watching us to get a me
乔安·沃特金斯在那儿，我拿着一张写着一句台词的纸，她问，你准备好开始了吗？我说好，他就在那儿看着我们，让我把台词
deliver it to her and I just go line and he burst out laughing and I got the job not a comedy but he was I think he was so he was like this motherfucker
念给她听，然后我就说了声“台词”，他突然大笑起来，然后我就得到这份工作了，这不是喜剧，但我猜他当时觉得，这个王八蛋
was this for sopranos? Sabratos yeah you were on the sopranos? Yeah I know that's a lot of people say wait come on really? I didn't know Can you believe I still have not watched that show?
这是为《黑道家族》吗？《黑道家族》，对。你演过《黑道家族》？对。我知道，很多人都说，等等，真的吗？我不知道。你能相信我还没看过那部剧吗？
I haven't either. It's real good. It's real good. It's going to be a hit, I hear. All right, come on, here we go. Jamie, let's get to your guests. I mean, let's get to your guests. I mean, she's probably left or asleep by now.
我也没看。它真的很棒。真的很棒。我听说它会大火。好了，快来，我们开始吧。杰米，我们来谈谈你的嘉宾。我是说，我们来谈谈你的嘉宾。我是说，她现在可能已经离开或者睡着了。
Here we come. Wait a second. Let me pull up the notes. Here we go. Here we go. Guys. Yes. Today, we have an actor that I met once very briefly and was as knocked out by her charm
我们来了。等一下。让我调出笔记。我们上。我们上。伙计们。是的。今天，我们请到了一位我曾非常短暂地见过的演员，她的魅力和热情正如你所想象的那样，深深打动了我。
and warmth as you would think that you would be. She's one of our biggest stars, an incredibly successful producer. She kills it in both comedy and drama, big films, and small. She has box office success as well as critical praise. Her nominations are numerous, including two for an Academy Award. She knows how to hold her breath for five minutes. She's a trained pickpocket in Will. She plays ice hockey competitively.
她是我们的超级巨星之一，也是一位极其成功的制片人。她在喜剧和正剧领域都大获成功，无论是大片还是小制作。她既有票房成功，也有评论界的好评。她的提名不计其数，包括两次获得奥斯卡奖提名。她知道如何在水下憋气五分钟。她是一个有训练的小偷，威尔。她极具竞争意识地打冰球。
She's at the top of the mountain folks, but is cleared an hour for a good old smartless chat and giggle. And I couldn't be more grateful to her. Gang, please welcome Ms. Margo Robbie. No. Oh, bang. Hey, Margo. Hi, Margo.
各位，她正站在群山之巅，但却腾出了一个小时来和我们进行一场美妙的老式 Smartless 聊天和大笑。对此我万分感激。各位，请欢迎玛格特·罗比女士。不。哦，砰。嘿，玛格特。嗨，玛格特。
What's going on, Margo? She's a big Rangers fan. I am. I've been seeing here, giggling, listening to you guys. I'm sorry. That was really fun. We tried to keep it tight. That was my favorite part.
最近怎么样，玛格特？她是个超级游骑兵队球迷。我是。我一直在这里咯咯笑，听你们聊天。对不起。那真的很有趣。我们尽量保持紧凑。那是我的最爱。
Yeah, I love the Rangers. Have you guys seen each other out there at the garden? No. No? I've seen you there. You know, I'm, yeah, I'm incognites. but I'm short for incognito. I have to say, before we keep talking about hockey, which I hope we do, Will, I have to say,
对，我喜欢游骑兵队。你们在花园球馆见过彼此吗？没有。没有？我在那儿见过你。你知道，我，是的，我很低调。但我很矮，不适合低调。我得说，在我们继续谈论曲棍球之前——我希望我们能继续——威尔，我必须说，
I fucking loved is this thing on. And I, you are so good in it. And I swear to God, as soon as I finished, this is a good. Literally, as soon as I finished watching it, the first thing I said, I was like, give the man the Oscar. Like, you were so unreal in it. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much.
我他妈太喜欢《这玩意儿开着吗》了。你在里面演得太棒了。我发誓，我一看完，真的，这很棒。真的，我一看完，我说的第一句话就是，把奥斯卡给这个男人。就像你在里面的表现太不真实了。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。
And now, let's have your review on this look, this new look. You in love with them as I am? Honestly, quite the reveal when I whipped off the piece of paper from the screen just there. You look great. All right. Thank you. You look 10 as well. Have you been on holiday?
现在，让我们听听你对这个造型、这个新造型的评价。你像我一样爱上它了吗？老实说，刚才我从屏幕上扯下那张纸的时候，真是一个巨大的揭晓。你看起来真棒。好吧。谢谢。你也显得才十岁。你去度假了吗？
It's a new bronzer. Right? Jason's new line, he does a lot of men's skin care. This one is water resistant. It's good for all climates. Won't leak on you, won't run. This one is called early June. So it's not too heavy.
这是一种新的古铜粉。对吧？杰森的新产品线，他做了很多男士护肤品。这款是防水的。适合所有气候。不会滴落，不会化掉。这款叫“六月初”。所以不会太厚重。
It just looks like the summer's started. It's working for you. Margo. So nice to meet. You. I mean, this is so cool. Thank you guys. How exciting.
它看起来就像夏天刚刚开始。这很适合你。玛格特。很高兴见到你。我是说，这太酷了。谢谢你们。太令人兴奋了。
And I had no idea about the hockey thing. You play hockey? You still play hockey? Do you know what? I don't have, I haven't for a couple of years, but I loved the Mighty Ducks when I was a kid, the movie. And I desperately wanted to play ice hockey, but I'm from a place called the Gold Coast in Australia. And there is no ice. And so there was no way to play ice hockey.
我完全不知道曲棍球的事。你打曲棍球？你还在打曲棍球？你知道吗？我没有，我已经好几年没打了，但我小时候很喜欢《野鸭队员》那部电影。我极其渴望打冰球，但我来自澳大利亚一个叫黄金海岸的地方。那里没有冰。所以根本没法打冰球。
So I ended up playing field hockey all through school. And when I got to America, the first thing I did, I was like, I'm going to play ice hockey. I'm here. I've made it in America. I can finally live out this dream. And so I joined an ice hockey team. Really? And I hadn't really ever ice skated.
所以我最后整个学生时代都在打草地曲棍球。当我来到美国时，我做的第一件事就是，我要去打冰球。我在这里。我在美国成功了。我终于可以实现这个梦想了。所以我加入了一支冰球队。真的吗？我其实从来没滑过冰。
Margot, as a Canadian, the nation of Canada is behind you. You are all of a sudden you've reached elite status in Canada. It was so fun. Now, was this before or after the skating training for us? by Tanya. Well before. It would have been very helpful if this came after that. But no, it was well before.
玛格特，作为一个加拿大人，加拿大全国都在支持你。你突然在加拿大达到了精英地位。这太有趣了。现在，这是在塔尼娅的滑冰训练之前还是之后？早得多。如果这在后面发生会很有帮助。但不是，早得多。
So I hadn't really skated before. I had like here and there like, you know, I don't know, just a few times maybe in my life, but not really. And I kind of, I think I just thought, oh, just run. And there's so much padding that honestly it was fine. But I played in a co-ed team. And there was only one other girl on the team. But you know when you're in all your gear,
所以我之前其实没怎么滑过冰。我有过零星几次，你知道，我不知道，我一生中可能只有几次，但并不多。我有点，我想我当时只是想，哦，就跑呗。而且有那么多护具，老实说没事的。但我加入了一支男女混合球队。队里只有另一个女孩。但你知道，当你穿着全套装备时，
you can't really tell that you're a girl. You know, like, I just looked like a very small guy. I had a problem with that one Saturday night. Go ahead. Hey, man, you need to ride. Okay, I want to hear more about that. Yeah, so I just lived like a small dude on the team, so I'd get picked on.
你根本看不出你是个女孩。你知道，就像，我看起来只是个很小的家伙。我有一周六晚上遇到了麻烦。请讲。嘿，老兄，你需要搭车吗。好的，我想听听更多关于这个的事。对，我当时就以一个小男生的身份在队里生活，所以我会挨欺负。
They would check me so hard. But, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's pretty balsy. And then I take off the helmet at the end of the game. They'd be like, oh, shit, sorry, I didn't know you were a girl. But you never got any, you didn't get any, you didn't tune anybody up. You didn't get any fights, right?
他们会狠狠地冲撞我。但是，对，对，对。这挺有种的。然后比赛结束我摘下头盔。他们会说，哦，靠，对不起，我不知道你是女的。但你从来没有，你没有把谁收拾一顿吗？你没有打过架，对吧？
fights? No, no, no. I was way smaller than it, bro. Wow, that's cool. All right, so you're out there in Australia and you are, you're enjoying, was it, done a tiny bit of research, was it, was it, was it the infatuation with Harry Potter that got you really excited about movies and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, that, that's what started, where did, where did, where did it, where did it
打架？没有，没有，没有。我比他们小得多，兄弟。哇，这太酷了。好吧，所以你在澳大利亚，你在，你挺享受，是吗，做了一点点研究，是，是，是对《哈利·波特》的迷恋让你对电影真正感到兴奋，然后，然后，然后，这一切是从哪里，从哪里，从哪里
all start out there? because mom nor dad was part of any of this stuff. No, no one's in the biz in my family. I had never met anyone who'd even so much as walked on a film set. Yeah, you were on a farm, right? Until I was, I was, I spent a lot of time on a farm, but I myself was not on a farm. I was on property, but a lot.
开始的呢？因为爸爸妈妈都不从事这行。没有，我家没有人从事这行。我从来没见过任何一个甚至踏足过电影片场的人。对，你在农场长大的，对吧？直到我，我，我在农场度过了很多时间，但我自己并没有在农场。我住在庄园里，但很多。
But, no, I don't know. I was just always obsessed with movies. I would just watch them again and again. Like we had a, you know, like most kids from the 90s, like we had a collection of videos, and I'd just watch them to death, and then I'd recreate them, and, like, I was just... And Harry Potter was a big part of them? I was obsessed with the books.
但是，不，我不知道。我只是从小就对电影痴迷。我会一遍又一遍地看。就像我们有一个，你知道的，就像大多数90年代的孩子一样，我们有一堆录像带，我会看到烂熟于心，然后我会重现它们，就像，我只是……《哈利·波特》是其中很大一部分吗？我对那些书着迷。
Yeah. So, no, that really didn't bleed into my, like, movie obsession. I was just obsessed with movies and watching them, and, yeah, my mom just used to watch me, like, I'd regurgitate, like, she'd be there making dinner in the kitchen, and I'd just be reenacting something. She kept being, like, how are you, how are you remembering all this? Where is this coming from? Is there one that you would do over and over again?
对。所以，不，这并没有真正融入到我的，类似于，对电影的痴迷中。我只是对电影和看电影痴迷，而且，对，我妈妈过去常常看着我，比如我像复读机一样，她当时在厨房做饭，而我只是在重演某些情节。她总是问，你怎么，你怎么能记住所有这些？这都是从哪来的？有没有哪个是你一遍又一遍去做的？
Is there a particular actor or actress that you were like, oh, God. Goldie Horn, I was big. I loved everything she did. Yeah, likewise. And then there was like, the fifth element was like my favorite film when I was and so I'd try and recreate all those like action sequences. And I was, yeah, I was a bit of a dramatic.
有没有哪个特定的男演员或女演员让你觉得，哦，天哪。戈尔迪·霍恩，我超级喜欢。我喜欢她做的一切。对，我也是。然后还有像，我小时候最喜欢的电影是《第五元素》，所以我试着重现所有这些动作戏。我当时，对，我有点戏剧化。
How funny was Chris Tucker in that, yeah. So good. What, then what, what, so then, so you go down to. Melbourne, you get a couple of jobs there such that you feel like, well, maybe this can arm me with the kind of experience and position in the community somewhat that I can go to America and try to parlay that into something bigger, better? Totally. Yeah. I mean, I was on, yes, I was on the Gold Coast, and which ironically now, a lot of movies are shooting on the Gold Coast, but growing up, it felt very far away.
克里斯·塔克在里面多滑稽啊，对。太棒了。什么，然后呢，然后，所以你去了……墨尔本，你在那里找到几份工作，让你觉得，好吧，这或许能为我在社区里提供某种经验和地位，让我可以去美国，并试着把这些转化为更大、更好的东西？完全是。对。我的意思是，我在，是的，我在黄金海岸，而讽刺的是，现在很多电影都在黄金海岸拍摄，但在我成长过程中，它感觉非常遥远。
So if you really wanted to do anything, you know, the big. because shows were all in Sydney and Melbourne. I ended up eventually finding my way into an audition for, like, practically a student film and ended up doing that and through that, you know how things are. Like, you do one unpaid thing. It leads to another unpaid thing. And then eventually someone pays you to do it.
所以如果你真的想做点什么，你知道，大的。因为节目都在悉尼和墨尔本。我最终设法去参加了一个试镜，类似于学生电影，最后拍了那个，通过那个，你知道事情是怎么样的。就像，你做了一件没有薪水的事。它导致另一件没有薪水的事。然后最终有人付钱让你做。
And you're about 16, 17, 18? 16, yes. I was in my final year of high school. And then I ended up getting a guest role on a TV show that shot in Melbourne. So that kind of took me to the big smoke. And then once I was in Melbourne, I could quickly parlay like one guest role into another guest role in a TV show with the same casting director. And then while I was in Melbourne, I auditioned for Neighbors, which is a big, Soap Australia. Oh, yeah, the biggest.
你大概16、17、18岁？16岁，是的。我当时正读高中最后一年。然后我终于在一部在墨尔本拍摄的电视剧里得到了一个客串角色。所以这算把我带到了大城市。一旦我到了墨尔本，我就可以迅速把一个客串角色转化为同一个选角导演的另一部电视剧的客串角色。然后在墨尔本期间，我为《邻居》试镜，这是一部澳大利亚的大肥皂剧。哦，对，最大的一部。
Oh, you've heard of it? Of course, yeah, yeah. I'm up on all things, Australia. Except for I will say I'm ignorant enough that I didn't realize that Gold Coast was the name of the actual city. I thought it was just kind of an area, but it's the actual not. I know. It's kind of confusing. And you also say, you say the Gold Coast, not like.
哦，你听说过？当然，对，对。我对澳大利亚的一切都很了解。除了我得说我够无知的，我没意识到黄金海岸是那个城市的真实名字。我以为它只是某种地区，但它其实不是。我知道。这有点令人困惑。而且你也说，你说黄金海岸，而不是像。
Like in, I don't, you don't live in Melbourne, you live in Sydney, but you live on the Gold Coast, even though that's the name of the city. Oh, wow. Yeah, that's up north, northeast, like, Brisbane? Yeah, exactly. An hour drive from Brisbane, an hour drive from Byron. And where are you today? Where are we finding you today?
就像在，我不知道，你不住在墨尔本，你住在悉尼，但你住在黄金海岸，尽管那是城市的名字。哦，哇。对，那在北部，东北部，像布里斯班？对，正好。距离布里斯班一小时车程，距离拜伦一小时车程。你今天在哪？今天我们在哪里找到你？
I'm in LA. Oh, you are. Okay. We're about to start the junket for Wuthering Heights, which is a film that we've got coming out. Oh, I can't wait for that. We're going to get to that. It's so good guys. I can't wait.
我在洛杉矶。哦，原来你在。好吧。我们正准备开始宣传《呼啸山庄》，这是我们即将上映的一部电影。哦，我等不及了。我们一会儿要谈到那个。真的太棒了，伙计们。我等不及了。
Words I never thought I'd say. No, I know. We'll hold you to that. I mean, I'm excited. But, all right, so what's going on with school at this moment? So you're in your last year high school. Are you thinking about college? Are you thinking about another career that might be more predictable,
这些话我从没想过自己会说。不，我知道。我们可记着呢。我的意思是，我很兴奋。但是，好吧，那么这个时候学校那边怎么样？所以你正读高中最后一年。你在考虑上大学吗？你在考虑另一份可能更有前途的职业吗，
something that you can count on more? I didn't really know what I was going to, because it still hadn't occurred to me that I could do acting as a job. job, even though I had started doing these like small unpaid things on the Gold Coast. So about halfway through high school, I started, you know, I did my first like, you know, the thing that I described as like a student film. It's like a independent film that never got distribution. So I don't really know what to call it other than a tiny micro budget film. And so I did two of those. I did, I would do commercials for free and, you know, whatever. And then, uh, the job in Melbourne
那种你可以更多依赖的东西？我其实不知道我要去做什么，因为我当时还没意识到我可以把演戏当成一份工作，尽管我已经开始在黄金海岸做这些无薪的小事情。所以在高中过半的时候，我开始，你知道的，我做了我的第一个，你知道的，我称之为学生电影的东西。那是一部从未获得发行的独立电影。所以我真的不知道该怎么称呼它，除了是一部微成本电影。所以我拍了两部。我拍过免费的广告，你知道，诸如此类。然后，在墨尔本的工作
kind of timed out at the end of high school. So it turned out pretty great that I got to finish my childhood really. And then, you know, two months later, I got the job on neighbors. And then I've been working professionally ever since. So you thought, no, I don't have time for college. Don't have time to get a backup thing. Well, I actually, to be honest,
差不多在高中结束时到期了。所以这结果挺棒的，我真的能过完我的童年。然后，你知道，两个月后，我得到了《邻居》的工作。从那以后我一直从事专业表演。所以你当时想，不，我没时间上大学。没时间找个备选方案。好吧，其实，老实说，
I didn't have the money to go to uni anyway. And I kind of thought, this is crazy. Am I really going to go to, you know, the thing is, like, you finish school, you go to university. And I know it's like that in America, too, like go off to college. But I was like, but there's, I don't know that there's something I want study specifically. Am I going to put myself in crazy debt for what? I was like, that's insane.
我无论如何也没有钱去上大学。而且我当时想，这太疯狂了。我真的要，你知道的，事情是这样的，你读完书，然后去上大学。我知道美国也是这样，比如去上大学。但我觉得，但是，我不知道有没有什么是我特别想学的。我要为了什么而背负疯狂的债务？我觉得，这太疯狂了。
So I couldn't get my head around that. Yeah, because you were lucky enough to know at a young age exactly what you wanted to do, which is great. But don't most, most kids, I mean, I'm talking to my daughters about this now. It's like you don't, you don't, there's no pressure to like know what your career is going to be, at least in your first two years. Isn't it like the third and fourth year where you have to declare your major? I think it's a bit different in America. I feel like in America, Oh, by the way, all I wanted to do was go to college in America because watching movies, it looked like the funnest thing in the whole world. And it would be like, why?
所以我无法接受这一点。对，因为你很幸运，在很小的时候就知道自己想做什么，这太棒了。但难道大多数，大多数孩子——我正跟我女儿们谈论这个。这就像你不知道，你没有压力去知道你的职业会是什么，至少在前两年。难道不是到了第三年和第四年才必须申报主修专业吗？我觉得美国有点不同。我觉得在美国，哦，顺便说一句，我当时只想去美国的大学，因为看电影时，它看起来是全世界最好玩的事情。而且会觉得，为什么？
What do you want to study? I'm like, oh, I don't care about what I would want. I just want to go to college in America. That's exactly why you go. I want to go to a frat fraternity party and drink out of red cups and all that stuff. And so I think I get the impression that for you guys in America, it's like you go to college to have a college experience. And at some point during that experience, you realize,
你想学什么？我说，哦，我不在乎我想学什么。我只想去美国的大学。这就是你去的真正原因。我想去参加兄弟会派对，用红塑料杯喝酒，诸如此类。所以我认为，给我的印象是，对你们美国人来说，就像你去上大学是为了体验大学生活。而在那种体验的某个时刻，你会意识到，
oh, I really like this class I'm taking. and now I'm going to shift in that direction. It's not really so much like that in Australia. You kind of have to decide in high school what it is that you, so you're like, oh, I want to be a lawyer, or I want to do business or something, and then you pick your degree and then you do that degree. And it's a little shorter as well.
哦，我真的很喜欢我上的这门课，现在我要朝着这个方向发展。在澳大利亚其实不太一样。你必须在高中时就决定你想要什么，所以你会想，哦，我想成为一名律师，或者我想做生意什么的，然后你选择你的学位，然后去读那个学位。而且它也稍短一些。
You can even do your full degree in like two and a half years in Australia. You can kind of back it up like that. My experience was like, I feel like I'm just going to go and waste my time doing this when I know that that's not where. I just want to go and start. start life now. And were you doing what your parents wanted you to do, too? Was that part of it?
你在澳大利亚甚至可以在两年半内完成全部学位。你可以像那样压缩学程。我的经历是，我觉得我只是去白白浪费时间，而我知道那并不是我想要的。我只想现在就开始生活。你当时是在按父母的意愿做事吗？这也是其中一部分吗？
Who me? Yeah, you. Yeah, a little bit. Tell me your name one more time. You're handsome. Look how handsome this guy. What is he was? He's handsome guy on the single-d-air?
谁，我？对，你。对，有一点。再告诉我一次你的名字。你长得真帅。看看这家伙多帅。他在单打独斗里是个帅哥吗？
Margo, I remember in college, we used to have parties and we'd, you know, lug the keg up the stairs. Yeah, totally. In this apartment. Totally, and we'd charge $3 a cup when you come in, we'd buy the kegs.
玛格特，我记得在大学里，我们以前常开派对，然后我们，你知道，把大桶啤酒扛上楼梯。对，完全是。在这个公寓里。完全是，我们进门时收3美元一杯，我们买大桶啤酒。
We'd make all this money. And at the end of the, the night, the floor would just be trashed with a beer everywhere in our apartment. And at that age, you just kind of don't care. No, that's the dream. That's all I wanted. Do you know what? Part of me was, you know, part of me was like, oh, no, I started acting like I said, other neighbors, whatever. And I was like, oh, I haven't gone to university. And I guess I'm never going to at this point. Does that mean I'm, am I dumb? And I remember, I remember asking my sister. I look in the mirror and say that to makes up every day.
我们赚了所有的钱。到了深夜，地板上全都是啤酒，我们的公寓一团糟。在那个年龄，你根本不在乎。不，那是梦想。那是我唯一想要的。你知道吗？我有一部分，你知道，我有一部分心想，哦，不，我开始演戏了，就像我说的，还有《邻居》什么的。然后我想，哦，我没有上过大学。我想我到这个时候永远也不会上了。这是否意味着我，我很笨？我记得，我记得问过我姐姐。我每天看着镜子也会这么对自己说。
I almost wanted to check that this didn't mean I wasn't, you know, it didn't mean I wasn't smart. My sister was, you know, we're very, very, very different people. And so she was studying to be an accountant in university, something I never would have done. But I remember saying, I was like, hey, can I do one of your assignments, one of your uni assignments? Because I just need to check that I,
我几乎想确认一下这并不意味着我不是，你知道的，这并不意味着我不聪明。我姐姐，你知道的，我们是非常、非常、非常不同的人。所以她在大学里学做会计，这是我绝对不会做的事。但我记得我说过，我说，嘿，我能做一份你的作业吗，你的大学作业？因为我只是需要确认一下，
that acting is not making me dumb. And I did it. And by the way, like numbers and accounting is not my first. forte at all. And I got like an A-minus. And I was like, okay, cool. And then I felt good after that. I was like, I'm good.
演戏没有把我变笨。然后我做了。顺便说一句，数字和会计绝对不是我的强项。我居然拿了个A减。然后我想，哦，酷。然后我之后感觉好多了。我就想，我挺好的。
I can do it. I know I can do it if I need to. Because of life experience. Well, I mean, I studied. It was all about, you know, cognitive dissonance and some boring shit. Yeah. But yeah. We'll be right back.
我能做到。如果需要的话，我知道我能做到。因为有生活阅历。好吧，我的意思是，我学过。那都是关于，你知道的，认知失调和一些无聊的屁事。对。但没错。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. All right. So you get to Hollywood. You got, well, it's not Hollywood first, right? No. So I was on Neighbors for three years, which is a pretty intense. and very, very fun and amazing training sort of thing as a young actor. Yeah, and so I did that for three years.
现在回到节目中。好的。所以你到了好莱坞。你拿到了，好吧，一开始不是好莱坞，对吧？没有。所以我在《邻居》待了三年，那是一个相当高强度、非常、非常有趣且令人惊叹的年轻演员训练营。对，我做了三年。
And then when my contract finished, I started about six months into that job on Neighbors. I'm looking around, you've got a cast of, say, 30 people aging from eight years old to 80 years old. And it's, you know, I looked around and I was like, okay, so some people are life is here. Some people have, you know, just made a life just from acting. And I'd ask the cast members, I was like, so you don't have any side jobs, you don't have a second job that you go do? And they're like, no, just this. And I was like, wow, okay, so you can make enough money doing this that you can like pay for a house and put your kids through school. And they're like, yeah.
然后当我的合同到期时，我在《邻居》工作了大约六个月后。我环顾四周，你有一个演员阵容，比方说30个人，年龄从8岁到80岁不等。然后，你知道，我环顾四周心想，好吧，所以有些人的生活就在这里。有些人，你知道的，仅凭演戏就过上了生活。我会问演员同事，我说，所以你们没有副业，你们没有第二份工作可以去做吗？他们说，没有，只有这个。然后我想，哇，好吧，所以你靠这个赚的钱足够付房租，还能供孩子上学。他们说，是的。
And I was like, oh, excellent, great. I'm going to do this then. So I'm going to be an actor then. Great. And then I was looking at some of the younger cast members who would. So there was kind of three choices or neighbors. Either one, you can't keep up. You get fired.
然后我想，哦，太好了，棒极了。那我也要这么做。所以我接下来要当演员。太棒了。然后我看着一些年轻的演员。
And it's like a revolving door. So, like, you need to be able to keep up. Number two, you are great and you stay and you can be on there for like 20, 30 years. You know, it's a long-running. So, or option three, you do it for a little bit and then you make the jump to America and you try your luck in America. So I knew that I wanted to be in Hollywood and do like American films. Margo, just to be clear, there have been a lot of members, cast members over the years from neighbors who have done that and gone to America and done great things, right? Yeah, and home in a way.
所以在《邻居》里大概有三种选择。第一，你跟不上。你被解雇了。这就像一扇旋转门。所以，你需要能够跟上。第二，你很棒，你留下来，你可以在那里待个20、30年。你知道，这是一个长寿的节目。所以，或者第三个选择，你演了一段时间，然后跳槽去美国，去美国碰碰运气。所以我知道我想去好莱坞拍美国电影。玛格特，澄清一下，多年来《邻居》里有很多演员都这样做过，去了美国并且发展得很好，对吧？对，还有《聚散离合》。
So like the two main so neighbors and home and. in a way. So it's like Kylie Minogue was on Neighbors and Chris Hemsworth was on Home and Away. Wow. Wow. Wow. Yeah. That's wow. All right. So when you, then when you get to Hollywood, is there is there a safety net? Do you come with a bag of money? Do you have an agent ready? There's an Aussie. There's an Aussie mafia ready made for you. Yes. It, uh, yeah, it's, no, like truly, it's like being on Ramsey Street, which is like the street in the show. It was like just being on Ramsey Street again, but in America. So who's taking care of you? You, well, you're your fellow Aussies that have been on soaps as well
所以就像两个主要的，所以《邻居》和《聚散离合》。所以凯莉·米洛曾在《邻居》里，克里斯·海姆斯沃斯曾在《聚散离合》里。哇。哇。哇。对。太惊人了。好吧。所以当你，当你到达好莱坞时，有没有安全网？你带着一袋钱来的吗？你准备好经纪人了？那里有一个现成的澳大利亚黑手党。是的。它，呃，是的，不，真的，就像在拉姆齐街一样，那是剧里的那条街。就像再次身处拉姆齐街，只不过在美国。所以是谁在照顾你？你，好吧，就是和你一样演过肥皂剧的澳大利亚同胞，
and you sleep on their couches and everyone like shares info of like okay because by the way when I moved here it was 16 years ago so I was 20 I moved five days after I finished on neighbors I was quite keen to get here and yeah there was no Uber there was no like it was a different time there was pilot season you had to learn how to drive on the other side of the road well not just that that wouldn't have been a problem it was getting a car you can't actually rent a car to you're 21 and I was still 20 and so I asked the Aussie you know like our Aussie mafia was like you know what do I do if I need to get a car to get around to these auditions
你睡在他们的沙发上，每个人都分享信息，比如，好吧，因为顺便说一句，我搬来这里时是16年前，所以我20岁，我在《邻居》杀青五天后就搬来了，我非常渴望来到这里。对，当时没有优步，没有，那是一个不同的时代。有试播季，你必须学会开右舵车。好吧，不仅如此，那本来不是问题，问题是租车。你不到21岁其实是不能租车的，我当时才20岁。所以我问澳大利亚人，你知道的，我们的澳大利亚黑手党就说，你知道如果我需要一辆车去赶这些试镜，我该怎么办？
and they're like okay I know a guy and so you'd go to this the guy and he would rent you a car kind of off the books or whatever and then you drive around to your auditions all that Russell Crowe's got a little side gig out and see me valley well I ended up crashing that car on the way and this was not a guy that you you know I didn't get the impressions as a guy that you messed with, but I crashed his car, and I was really scared to tell him. Anyways, he took the car off me, obviously. And then I still needed a car to get around to auditions,
他们就说，好吧，我认识一个人。于是你会去找这个人，他会有点私下里把车租给你之类的，然后你开着车去参加试镜。罗素·克劳在瑟米山谷有个小副业。好吧，我在路上把那辆车撞了，而这显然不是那种你可以，你知道，我当时觉得这不是一个你可以随便招惹的人。但我把他的车撞了，我非常害怕告诉他。不管怎样，他理所当然地把车从我这儿收回去了。然后我还是需要一辆车去赶试镜，
and I went back to the Aussies, and I was like, what do you do when you piss off that guy? Like, is there another guy that you can rent a car from? And they're like, yes, he's called the dodgy Romanian. And I was like, okay. And I rented a car from the dodgy Romanian, as he was called. And it was like this gold-colored, oh, God, I haven't thought about this in you.
我又去找了澳大利亚同胞，我说，你把那家伙惹毛了该怎么办？呃，还有别的可以租车的人吗？他们说，有，他叫“古怪的罗马尼亚人”。我说，好吧。然后我就从那个被称为“古怪的罗马尼亚人”的人手里租了一辆车。那是金黄色的，哦，天哪，我好几年没想起这个了。
It was like this gold color, not a Lincoln, but like it looked like, it was like a boxy color like from the 80s. A big one. And this guy was like very few words, very, you know, like here's the keys, give me the cash. We're not going to chit chat. Just one thing. We don't have an offensive Romanian accent at you? No, thank God. It was like, don't open the trunk ever.
这是一种金色，不是林肯，但看起来像，就像那种80年代那种方方正正的颜色。很大的一辆。然后这家伙话非常少，你知道的，就那种，钥匙给你，把现金拿来。我们不闲聊。只有一件事。我们没有对你带有什么冒犯性的罗马尼亚口音吧？没有，感谢上帝。就好像，绝对不要打开后备箱。
No, come on, really? I am not joking. Because I just don't open the trunk. And I was petrified. And I, no, I desperately. wanted to make it in Hollywood. I'm like, I'm not going on little side quest here to open this trunk and get caught up in whatever is happening here. I am never going to open this trunk. And anyways, I ended up again crashing in this car. I was... What's your battle with you?
不，拜托，真的吗？我可没开玩笑。因为我就是不打开后备箱。我当时吓坏了。而且我，不，我极度。渴望能在好莱坞闯出名堂。我想，我可不想去搞什么支线任务，去打开这个后备箱，然后卷入这里正在发生的任何事情中。我绝不会打开这个后备箱。总之，我最后还是把这辆车给撞了。我当时……你跟自己做过什么思想斗争吗？
You know what? I was always like doing my makeup and changing on the way to auditions and stuff and not paying... It was, yeah, it was a bit of a chaotic time. Anyways, I crashed in this car and I was panicking. I was like, holy shit. What do I do? There's no... You don't even call in. insurance. You got to call the dodgy Romanian and tell him that I've just crashed his car and he didn't kill me, I suppose. And so I called him and he's like, where are you? And I was like, I gave him the address. I was
你知道吗？我总是边去试镜的路上边化妆换衣服，根本不注意……那确实，那是一段有点混乱的时期。总之，我把这辆车给撞了，当时我慌得不行。我想，天哪。我该怎么办？根本没有……你甚至都不能报警或走保险。你得打电话给那个不靠谱的罗马尼亚人，告诉他我刚把他的车给撞了，我想他应该不会杀了我吧。于是我给他打了电话，他问：你在哪？我说，我把地址给了他，我
somewhere in Venice, I think, and it was like nighttime and he was like, I'm coming to you. And I was like, oh God, no. And he rocked up with an associate and they got out of the car and they go to the trunk. He looked at the damage and he was like, okay. And I was like waiting to, I don't know, be executed. And he was like,
当时在威尼斯（Venice）附近吧，天色已黑，他说：我这就去找你。我当时想：哦天哪，不要。结果他带了个同伙轰轰烈烈地赶到了，他们下了车，径直走向后备箱。他看了看损坏情况，然后说：好吧。我当时正等着，不知道，被处决呢。结果他说：
did you open the trunk? And I was like, No, never. Like, I literally never. How dare you? And he goes, okay. And he just took the keys, and he drove away. No way. And I never saw him again.
你打开后备箱了吗？我说：没有，绝对没有。真的从来没有。你怎么能这么问？他说：好吧。然后他直接拿了钥匙，开车走了。不会吧。我再也没见过他。
I never got a bill for the damage to the car. Nothing. Truly. Oh, my God. Just went to into thin air. And I still, to this day, I don't know what was in the trunk. Yeah, what was in there? What was in?
我从来没有收到过车损账单。什么都没有。真的。哦，天哪。就这样凭空消失了。直到今天，我还是不知道后备箱里装的是什么。对啊，里面到底是什么？里面有什么？
Just some cash, just loose cash. That'd be nice. You can't deposit. Just junk. It might have just been junk in the trunk. Oh, God. Just too close. Oh, no.
只是一些现金，零散的现金。那倒挺好的。你没法存起来。只是一些破烂。里面可能真的就是一堆破烂。哦，天哪。太惊险了。哦，不。
Did you have junk in the trunk? Did you get to use the car enough to go to plenty of auditions? Did you get use out of the car before he crashed there? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I had a good couple weeks. So what was, so you come to America, let's say, Margo, what was the thing? What was the first American gig? Pan Am.
你的后备箱里有破烂吗？在你撞车之前，你用这辆车去参加足够多的试镜了吗？是的，是的，是的。我有相当不错的几个星期。那么，那么，你来到美国，比方说，玛格特，当时是怎么回事？你的第一份美国工作是什么？泛美航空（Pan Am）。
Is it Pan Am? Yeah, Pan Am. Remember that series? And that at the time, that was like, it was a TV show about the Pan Am. Oh, that's right. It was just a big, it was a big deal at the time. Good looking show. Yeah.
是泛美航空吗？对，泛美航空。还记得那个剧吗？当时那个剧，就是，这是一部关于泛美航空的电视剧。哦，对。那可是一部大制作，当时反响很大。演员颜值很高的剧。对。
It was, it was a TV show. I think at the time it was the most someone had spent on a pilot before. Yes. They spent like $10 million on the pilot or something like that. It doesn't seem like it's that long ago. I know. And that also now seems like a small budget for like a pilot. But yeah, it was a big deal and I had a role in that.
那是，那是一部电视剧。我想在当时，这是剧集试播集（pilot）投资最高的一次了。是的。他们为试播集花了大约1000万美元左右。感觉好像没过去多久。我知道。现在看来，这对于一部试播集来说似乎是一笔小预算。不过是的，当时这可是个大项目，我在里面有个角色。
So that was my first job. So I then moved to New York because we shot that at Steiner Studios in Brooklyn. So then I was living in New York for a year. And my roommate was Christina Ritchie. No way. No way. Wow. Yeah.
所以那是我的第一份工作。然后我搬到了纽约，因为我们在布鲁克林的斯坦纳制片厂（Steiner Studios）拍摄。于是我在纽约住了一年。我的室友是克里斯蒂娜·里奇（Christina Ricci）。不可能。不会吧。哇。对。
No way. So I've gone from being in Australia, like never having, you know, met a single famous person or seen a movie set or whatever to, yeah, living in the big scene. And then was this your first time in New York? Yes. Oh, my God. And what did you think of that? I suddenly, I couldn't comprehend how much of a city it was.
怎么可能。所以我从澳大利亚来到这里，从来没有，你知道的，见过任何一个名人和电影片场之类的，到，是的，生活在核心大舞台上。那是你第一次去纽约吗？是的。哦，天哪。你对此有什么感想？我当时简直无法理解，这城市竟然可以这么大。
The thing is where I grew up on the Gold Coast, like I mentioned, but my family's all from like inland, Queensland, like the farms, right? And so I had grown up thinking I was a city kid and I thought the Gold Coast was like, like the big smoke. And they'd always call me a city kid because, you know, I was on the Gold Coast. Then I moved to Melbourne for neighbors, and I was like, whoa, okay, this is a city.
问题是，我是在黄金海岸长大的，就像我提到的那样，但我家人其实都来自昆士兰州内陆，就是那些农场，对吧？所以我从小就觉得自己是个城市小孩，我以为黄金海岸就像是个，就像是个大都市。他们总是叫我城市小孩，因为，你知道的，我在黄金海岸嘛。后来为了拍《邻居》（Neighbours）我搬到了墨尔本，我当时想：哇，好吧，这才是城市。
I was like, oh my God, I can't believe I thought I was a city kid. I've never been to a city. Melbourne is a city. This is the craziest thing I've ever seen. And then I got to New York and I was like, okay, I don't even know anymore. This is a different level.
我当时想：天哪，我真不敢相信我以前觉得自己是个城市小孩。我从来没去过真正的城市。墨尔本才是城市。这是我见过最疯狂的事情。然后我到了纽约，心想：好吧，我彻底不知道了。这是完全不同的级别。
This is a city. Yeah, I loved it. I had the best, best, best time. Oh, my God. So you do panic. And then that sort of runs its course. And then you're sort of left wondering what's going to happen now, or was it just offers flooding in?
这才是真正的城市。是的，我太喜欢了。我度过了最棒、最棒、最棒的一段时光。哦，天哪。所以你拍了《泛美航空》。然后那部剧也算告一段落了。接着你大概就在琢磨接下来会发生什么，或者说是不是片约像雪花一样飞来？
No, they didn't pick up the back nine. So we kind of had an inkling that we weren't going to go to a season two. It's my job. And then I started auditioning at that point. I auditioned for Richard Curtis's film About Time, which I ended up getting a small role in. And then I also, like everyone else, I auditioned for the Wolf of Wall Street.
不，他们没有续订后九集（back nine）。所以我们其实有点预感，这部剧不会有第二季了。这是我的工作。然后我就开始参加试镜了。我去为理查德·柯蒂斯（Richard Curtis）的电影《时空恋旅人》（About Time）试镜，最后我在里面得到了一个小角色。然后我还和所有人一样，去为《华尔街之狼》（The Wolf of Wall Street）试镜。
So I sent in a self-tape for that, and I ended up getting that, and that was my first American film. No, wait, wait. So you sent in a self-tape for Wolfram Wall Street. So then how long was that process? Was that maybe two or three auditions before you got to Scorsese and Leo? No. No. I went from the tape to being in the room with Marty and Leo.
所以我寄了一段自拍试镜视频（self-tape）过去，最后我拿下了那个角色，那也是我的第一部美国电影。等等，等等。所以你为《华尔街之狼》寄了自拍试镜视频。那这个过程持续了多久？在你见到马丁（Scorsese）和小李子（Leo）之前，是不是经历了大概两三次试镜？没有。没有。我从交录像直接就到了和马蒂（Marty）和莱昂纳多（Leo）共处一室。
Christ. Wow. It was, there was no in-between. I don't know how it happened like that, because everyone I knew was sending in a tape, like everyone. So I never thought Martin Scorsese was going to see the tape. I just was hoping that Ellen Lewis, the casting director, was going to see the tape.
天呐。哇。真的，中间没有任何过渡。我都不知道它是怎么发生的，因为我认识的每个人都寄了录像，所有人都在寄。所以我从没想过马丁·斯科塞斯会对那段录像感兴趣。我当时只希望选角导演艾伦·刘易斯（Ellen Lewis）能看一看那段录像。
And, you know, I sent it in. I didn't hear back anything until I got the call saying, you're going to read in the room with Marty. How long was that? How long was that gap from the time you said? It was quite a while. Like, I can't remember that. Like you'd forgotten about it almost.
而且，你知道的，我寄了出去。直到我接到电话说：你要去和马蒂一起面对面试读剧本，我才听到回音。那有多久？从你寄出录像到接到通知，中间隔了多久？挺长一段时间的。具体我记不清了。就好像你几乎都把这事给忘了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like, you know, like, I don't know, maybe five weeks or something. I don't know. I get the feeling that maybe I was a bit of a wild card option because I think they had a couple of actresses read in the room with Marty and Leo to do a chemistry read sort of situation. I don't know, maybe I was like the wild card where they're like, I don't know, throw her in.
对，对，对。就好像，我不知道，大概五周左右吧？我记不清了。我有种感觉，我当时可能算是一个黑马选项，因为我觉得他们让好几位女演员去和马蒂、小李子一起在房间里试戏，主要是为了测试化学反应什么的。我不知道，也许我就是那个“黑马”，他们当时想的是：管他的，把她也扔进来试试。
I have no idea. You get a call from your agent, you're like, guess what? That tape you sent in, you're going to go meet Martin Scorsese. Well, no, they said you're going to go meet with Marty. And I didn't know who Marty was. I was like, Marty. And they're like, Marty is what people call Martin. Romanian.
我完全不知道。你接到经纪人的电话，你会想：你猜怎么着？你寄过去的那个录像，你要去见马丁·斯科塞斯了。哦，不，他们说的是你要去见马蒂。我当时都不知道马蒂是谁。我说：马蒂？他们说：马蒂就是大家对马丁的称呼。罗马尼亚人。
I was going to say it. Dodge you from Maine. So you're going to go meet with Marty and Leo and you're going to read with Leo for Marty. I mean, did they make you feel comfortable or were you nervous? They did. They did. And they gave me the role in the room as well.
我正想说呢。不靠谱的罗马尼亚人。所以你要去见马蒂和小李子，你要为马蒂和莱昂纳多对戏。我的意思是，他们有让你感到放松吗？还是说你很紧张？他们有。他们确实让我感到放松。而且他们当场就把这个角色给我了。
No, that's great. So the whole thing was crazy. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, walk us through that. Is it true that you actually? Is it true that you improvise a slap on Leo? Yes, it is true. It is true. It is true. Thank Christ that worked out.
哇，太棒了。所以整件事太疯狂了。等等，等等，等等，等等，给我们讲讲当时的情景。这是真的吗？真的像传说中那样，你即兴给了小李子一巴掌？是的，千真万确。千真万确。千真万确。谢天谢地最后成功了。
Because that could have gone a different way for sure. Okay, walk us through that. Okay. Okay, so the way that day went, I walk in, I walk in. First I go to Ellen Lewis's office to, like, have a quick pre-chat with her. The great Ellen Lewis. And she takes one look at what I'm wearing. And she was like, no, no, no, no, no.
因为这事本来完全可能走向另一个方向。好吧，给我们讲讲当时的过程。好的。好吧，事情是这样的，那天我走进去，走进去。首先我去了艾伦·刘易斯的办公室，和她简单聊了几句。伟大的艾伦·刘易斯。她看了看我穿的衣服。然后她说：不，不，不，不，不。
Like, she was like, you're going to go back downstairs. I think I was wearing, like, you know, my, like, boots and, like, jeans and like a, I don't know, long sleeve shirt or something. And she was like, absolutely not. You're going to go downstairs. You're going to walk that way. And you're going to walk into a place called Soho. There's lots of shops. and you're going to find a tight dress and the highest heels you can find,
就好像，她说：你得回楼下。我当时穿的好像是，你知道的，我的靴子、牛仔裤，还有一件，我不知道，长袖衬衫什么的。她就说：绝对不行。你现在下楼。朝那个方向走。走进一个叫苏荷（Soho）的地方。那里有很多商店。去找一条紧身裙和你能找到的最高的高跟鞋，
and then you're going to come back. And I was like, okay. And so I went and did that, and I came back in a new outfit. And then I, you know, went to the, you know, the audition room thing. And Marty and Leo were in there. And it was quite surreal. And we started doing the first scene. And I just, you know, I'd been on a soap where you have to,
然后你再回来。我说：好吧。于是我照办了，穿着一身新行头回来了。然后我，你知道的，就去了那个试镜的房间。马蒂和小李子都在里面。感觉非常超现实。我们开始演第一场戏，而我，你知道的，我以前演过肥皂剧，那种地方你必须，
you do like 60 pages a day and you have to be word perfect. Because it's multi-cams, they're switching. They're essentially editing as you do the scene. You are word perfect. So I start doing the scene. And it was all right and whatever. But Leo was like throwing in adlids and improvising. And I'd never ever improvised before.
你一天要拍60页剧本，而且台词必须一字不差。因为那是多机位拍摄，镜头在切换。他们基本上是在你演戏的同时就在进行剪辑。你的台词必须绝对精准。所以我开始演那场戏。感觉还行，什么的。但小李子一直在加台词、即兴发挥。我以前从来没有即兴表演过。
I'd never seen another actor improvised before. So I was a bit thrown. And I was like, well, that's not in the script. Wait, what's he doing? Okay. And I was like, oh my gosh. He doesn't know his lines. He's like, Leo doesn't learn.
我也从未见过其他演员即兴表演。所以我当时有点懵。我想：这剧本里没有啊。等等，他在干什么？好吧。我当时想：哦天哪。他台词不熟吗？他就像是，小李子不记台词的吗？
I was like, wow, he's improvving. Okay, shit. And so I thought. I didn't do very good in that scene, I think, because I was playing catch-up a little bit. And I thought, oh, God, I'm getting thrown out of this room in, like, 30 seconds. Like, I've got 30 seconds to make an impression because we are like, this is not impressive so far. And so I was like, okay, forget the lines, just go off script. And just, I just thought, I'm just going to use, like, every swear word I know.
我心想：哇，他在即兴发挥。好吧，死定了。所以我当时想。我觉得我那场戏演得不太好，因为我有点在疲于应付。我心想：哦天哪，我大概30秒内就要被赶出这个房间了。我有30秒的时间来留下一个好印象，因为我们现在，目前的表现一点也不让人印象深刻。所以我当时想：好吧，忘掉台词吧，别按剧本演了。我当时就想，把我所有知道的脏话全用上。
And so they were like, in action. And I just, like, start a script. Because also, Leo can go, you know, like, if you don't get in there, he'll just keep going. and like he can do the scene without you sort of thing. So it's either like get yourself in there or you're like, you know, he can do. And you're in a Brooklyn accent for this? Yeah, Brooklyn accent, which is actually easier for an Aussie
然后他们喊了：开始。我立刻就脱离了剧本。因为小李子也很厉害，你知道的，如果你不接住他的戏，他就会一直演下去。他可以不带你把戏演完。所以要么你自己强势切入，要么你就只能看着他自己把戏演完。而且你当时还要带着布鲁克林口音？对，布鲁克林口音，这其实对澳大利亚人来说更容易，
because we don't do, you know, we don't hit our ars like that. So yeah, and then so I just started like, I jumped in quick. I was like, blah, blah, blah, and start screaming or whatever. And so I was like, okay, great. So we're doing this scene and now there's a bit of energy in the room and it's feeling good. And I was like, okay, great. You know, and then there was the last scene, third scene to do,
因为我们平时说话不怎么卷舌发r音。所以，是的，然后我就开始切入，我很快地插话。我说：巴拉巴拉巴拉，开始尖叫什么的。然后我想：好吧，太棒了。我们在演这场戏，现在房间里有了一点能量，感觉挺好。我想：太好了。你知道的，然后还有最后一场戏，第三场戏要演，
which ends in a line of now get over, here and kiss me and then it's the end of the scene. And so we end up, you know, I was, I think, feeling a little buzz that I did well in the second scene. So by, I was, you know, a little more bullshit in this third scene. And we get to the end and it's like, okay, now get over here and kiss me. And I thought to myself, wow, I could kiss Leonardo DiCaprio right now. Like, that would be so cool.
台词以“现在过来，吻我”结尾，然后整场戏就结束了。所以我们最后演到，我当时，觉得第二场戏演得不错，所以有点小兴奋。因此到了这第三场戏，我胆子也稍微大了一点。我们演到了结尾，台词是“好啦，现在过来吻我”。我当时心里想：哇，我此刻可以亲吻莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥了。天哪，那太酷了。
I could tell all my girlfriends back home that that happened. That would be like a life experience. And I was like walking towards him slowly having this thought of like, maybe I just do it. like, fuck it. And then I got close and I was like, nah, this character wouldn't do that. And I just went whack and slapped him instead. And it was like, dead silent.
我可以把这事告诉老家的所有闺蜜。那绝对是一次人生经历。我一边这么想着，一边慢慢朝他走去，心里盘算着：要不我真的亲他一下？管他的。然后我走近了，又想：不对，这个角色才不会这么做。于是我直接“啪”地一下，狠狠地扇了他一巴掌。当时现场一片死寂。
Like, you could hear a pin drop. And I was like, oh, my God, what have I just done? I'm going to get arrested. I think that's, you know, battery or like assault of some kind. Like, can I be sued? Do I go to jail for this? And then he and Marty just burst out laughing. And they were like, like, that's great.
安静得连根针掉在地上都能听见。我当时想：哦，天哪，我都干了些什么？我要被捕了。我觉得这属于，你知道的，故意伤害或者某种袭击。我会不会被告？我会不会为此坐牢？然后他和马蒂突然爆发出大笑。他们说：
That was amazing. And then they said, you've got the job right there. And they said, that again, let's do the scene again, do more improv, do that again. And anyway, so we workshopped the scenes for a little bit. And then I, you know, said, thank you. And I walked out of the room. And I got in the elevator and I, like, took my heels off.
太棒了。这太惊艳了。然后他们说：工作就是你的了，当场拿下。他们说：再来一次，把这场戏重演一遍，多做点即兴表演，再来一次。总之，我们又稍微排练了一下那些戏。然后我，你知道的，说了声谢谢，走出了房间。我走进电梯，
And I, like, did that, like, little silent jig dance to yourself. Like, oh, my gosh, that was so fun. I can't believe that just happened. And just as the elevator doors were about to close, Ellen Lewis was like, wait, come back into the room for one second. I was like, oh, okay. And I walked back in, my heels still in my hands. And they were standing there, like, just smiling.
把高跟鞋脱了下来，然后自己在那儿跳了一段无声的庆祝小舞。天哪，太好玩了。我真不敢相信刚才发生的一切。就在电梯门即将关上的时候，艾伦·刘易斯喊道：等等，回房间一下。我心想：哦，好吧。我又走了进去，手里还拎着高跟鞋。他们站在那里，
And I was like, what's up? And they were like, and Marty just, oh, Marty just held out his hands like this and guys would like to offer you the role. And then gave me the biggest hug. Oh, that's amazing. What a dream. So incredible.
面带微笑地看着我。我问：怎么啦？他们说，然后马蒂，哦，马蒂只是双手这样伸开，说：我们想把这个角色交给你。然后给了我一个大大的拥抱。哦，太棒了。简直像做梦一样。太不可思议了。
And yeah. That's amazing. Did they ever make the movie? Yeah. Did they end up making the movie, Sean wants to know? Yeah. Yeah, they got that one off the ground. Well, now, okay, so that was that amazing story.
是的。太惊人了。他们真的拍了那部电影吗？对。他们真的把那部电影拍出来了，肖恩想知道这个。对。对，他们真的把那个项目搞定了。好吧，现在，所以那就是那个神奇的故事。
Thank you for sharing that. Yeah, that was really cool. The film is stunning. Your work in it is stunning. It was so well received. Did things, I mean, a massive change for you in your life once that comes out. Was that a comfortable thing? I mean, something you've been working for for a long time.
谢谢你分享这些。是的，真的很酷。这部电影太惊艳了。你在里面的表演太惊艳了。大受欢迎。生活，我是说，自从那部电影上映后，你的生活发生了翻天覆地的变化。那是一种舒适的体验吗？我是说，这是你长期以来一直为之努力的事。
This was a bigger step than you probably imagined happening. Were you able to kind of like step up to it and hit it? in stride or was it a bit of an adjustment? Well, you know how it goes. It's like you make a movie and then it doesn't come out for a year. So your life kind of goes on for a year. And it didn't, it didn't occur to me that it, I would, do you know what? I just didn't know I was going to be in the movie as much as I ended up being in it.
这比你想象中迈出的步子要大得多。你能够顺其自然地适应并迎难而上，还是说这需要一个适应的过程？好吧，你知道情况是怎么样的。就像你拍了一部电影，然后它一年后才上映。所以你的生活还会照常过上一年。当时我并没有，我并没有意识到它会，你知道吗？我只是不知道我在电影里的戏份最后会有那么多。
I thought, because the set was so crazy and so much improvisation and so much like every day. It was like, we were like writing scenes the night before. Like my whole end sequence in that movie, we wrote like the night before in a room at like 3 a.m. We were like, it was meant to be just a scene where I'm. My character comes in and says, I want a divorce and she put some papers down. That's kind of it. And then we ended up kind of being like, oh, we need something more. And we workshop this whole thing, that whole sequence.
我以为，因为片场太疯狂了，有那么多的即兴发挥，每一天都充满变数。就好像我们在前一天晚上还在写剧本。我在那部电影里的整段结局序列，我们是在前一天晚上大概凌晨3点在一个房间里写出来的。本来只是一场简单的戏，我的角色走进来说：我要离婚，然后她拍下几份文件。差不多就这样。然后我们最后觉得，哦，我们需要更有冲击力的东西。于是我们一起构思了整个场景，整段序列。
So by the nature of the filming process, I thought, you know, there's a lot of experimenting going on, a lot of improv going on. Like, I'm sure most of this isn't going to make the cut. So I thought, I wonder how much I'll be in this movie. And I didn't see it until the night before the premiere. So I had no idea. Oh, no way. Yeah.
所以由于这种拍摄过程的性质，我想，你知道，里面有大量的实验，大量的即兴表演。我确信大部分内容最终都不会被剪进正片里。所以我当时想：不知道我在电影里会有多少镜头。直到首映式的那个晚上我才看到成片。所以当时我一无所知。哦，真的吗？对。
And then so I didn't really prepare for it. And I thought, oh, I'll be like a, you know, blink and you'll miss me sort of thing. like I'll be in and out. Like I just didn't think anyone was going to pay attention to me in that movie at all. So I wasn't, I wasn't really, I wasn't really, yeah, I mean,
所以我也根本没有为此做心理准备。我以为，哦，我大概就是那种，你知道的，一眨眼就会错过的龙套角色。就像打个酱油一样。我根本没想过会有人在那部电影里注意到我。所以我当时并没有，我真的没有，我真的没有，我是说，
you got Jonah Hill doing like the most incredible stuff. Everyone, like the cameos are endless. Like every day you'd come into work and people would be like Matthew McConaughey's the other day or like, you know, whatever. So,
你有乔纳·希尔（Jonah Hill）在里面做着极其精彩的表演。每个人，客串阵容简直没完没了。就像你每天去上班，大家都会说：马修·麦康纳（Matthew McConaughey）昨天来了，或者诸如此类的话。所以，
so, so, yeah, it just felt like I was one, one blip amongst a big canvas of, of, you know, chaos. And so I,
所以，所以，是的，我感觉自己只是在一幅巨大且混乱的画布上微不足道的一个小亮点。所以我，
yeah, I didn't really brace myself for how, how things would change after that. And I'd already done a bunch of jobs in between. Sure. You know, because I had a year. So, yeah, I don't know. Life got weird pretty quickly.
是的，我真的没有为之后事情会如何改变做好心理准备。而且在那期间我已经接拍了一堆其他工作了。当然。你知道的，因为我有一年的时间。所以，是的，我不知道。生活很快就变得奇奇怪怪的了。
Yeah, but then you go and you see it and you're like, wow. Yeah. Well, no, really, I was thinking, I was like, oh, shit, my family is about to see this. Oh, no. I organized a friends and family screening and I, like, sat down. And the credit started and I suddenly was like, oh, my God, I'm like naked and I'm fully naked and they're all about to see it. And, I mean, there's scenes where we're, like, having sex on a bed of cash. Like, my brother is right next to me.
是的，但随后你去看成片，心想：哇。对。好吧，说真的，我当时在想：哦，操，我的家人马上就要看到这个了。哦，不。我组织了一场亲友专场放映，然后我坐了下来。片头字幕亮起，我突然觉得：哦，天哪，我是全裸的，我是完全赤裸的，他们马上就要看到了。而且，你知道，有些戏是我们在一堆现金床上做爱的。我哥哥就坐在我旁边。
Like, oh, no. I was like, this is going to be the most uncomfortable thing ever. I never forget, at the end of that screening, I think my family were all a little bit stunned and, like, didn't know what to say, but felt like they should say, congrats or something. And my older brother, he was quite a blokey bloke, you know, quite an noisy bloke. he was just like,
就像，哦，不。我当时想：这将是有史以来最尴尬的事情。我永远不会忘记，在那场放映结束时，我的家人似乎都有点被震惊到了，不知道该说些什么，但又觉得应该说“恭喜”之类的话。我大表哥，他是个挺硬汉的家伙，你知道的，一个挺吵闹的澳洲硬汉。他当时就，
uh, uh, couldn't find the words. And I was like, you know what? We don't have to talk for a while. And he goes, great.
呃，呃，半天憋不出话来。我当时就说：你知道吗？我们接下来一段时间不用说话了。他说：太好了。
And just like kind of gave me a hit on the back and then walked out. We didn't talk for like months after that. And then when we did, we never mentioned it again. We're like, let's never talk about that. Oh my God.
然后就在我背上拍了一下，接着就走出去了。在那之后的几个月里我们都没怎么说话。等我们再说话时，也绝口不提这事。我们心想：永远别提这破事了。哦，天哪。
All right. How soon after that did you get pulled into the DC universe with Harley Quinn? Gosh, that must have been. Oh my gosh, that's right, Harley Quinn. Okay, so Wolf of Wall Street,
好了。在那之后多久，你被拉进了带有小丑女（Harley Quinn）的DC宇宙？天哪，那一定。哦，天哪，没错，小丑女。好吧，所以《华尔街之狼》，
2012. You did the movie before that, you did the movie with, what's that great one you did with Will Smith? Focus. Oh, I love that movie. Yeah, it's so fun, isn't it? It's a great movie. You're so good in that movie.
2012年。在那之前你拍了一部电影，你和，你和威尔·史密斯（Will Smith）合作过那部超棒的电影叫什么名字？《焦点》（Focus）。哦，我超喜欢那部电影。对，太有趣了，不是吗？那是一部很棒的电影。你在那里的表演太棒了。
Oh, thank you. That was so fun. Yeah, it must have been right after, it must have been after Focus, because Will and I had already done that movie, and then we worked together again in the first suicide scoredolls. And then where was Itania in all this? Itonia was after that.
哦，谢谢。太好玩了。是的，那一定是在之后，一定是在《焦点》之后，因为威尔和我已经合作过那部电影了，然后我们在第一部《自杀小队》（Suicide Squad）里又合作了。那《我，花样女王》（I, Tonya）是在这一切的什么节点？《我，花样女王》是在那之后。
After Harlequin? 2017 is when I Tonya either we filmed it or it came out in 2017. I love it. Yeah, that movie is so great. Your performances. I mean, everybody's so sick of talking about the one scene where they just hold on you in the mirror. No, I loved, because again, that was like an in-the-moment thing where, I don't know,
演完小丑女之后？2017年是《我，花样女王》要么开拍要么上映的时间。我太喜欢了。是的，那部电影太棒了。你的表演。我是说，大家是不是都对那场他们在镜子前特写你的戏讨论得厌烦了？不，我很喜欢，因为那同样是一个即兴发生的时刻，我不知道，
we'll set up and. Craig Gillespie, right? Yeah, Craig, who's the best, also in Ozzy. But yeah, I was kind of like, I was like, let me try something for a second. It might be lame, but let me try it. Oh my God, it was so powerful. That was incredible. And then afterwards, and I was like,
我们布置好场景，导演是克雷格·吉勒斯佩（Craig Gillespie），对吧？对，克雷格，他是最棒的，也是个澳大利亚人。但当时我大概是觉得：让我试着演一下。可能效果很烂，但让我试试。哦，天哪，太有张力了。那简直不可思议。然后结束后，我当时想：
was that too weird? And he was like kind of like really still and he's never still. He's like, he is fast. Like you think, I thought shooting neighbors, he is fast. Anyways, and he was like very still and he was like, that was something. And I was like, okay, cool. Do you me to do? And he's like, don't do anything else.
刚才那样是不是太诡异了？而他一动不动地站在那里，他平时可从来不会这么安安静静的。他这个人节奏很快。就像你以为，我想象拍《邻居》时那样，他动作快得很。总之，他当时非常安静，然后他说：刚才那段很有东西。我当时想：好的，cool。你需要我再来一条吗？他说：什么都别改了。
Let's move on. And I was like, wow. What a great feeling. That's the best. It's the best. You know, that feeling where you're like, oh, something electric just happened. Something. I don't know, maybe it's nothing,
我们进入下一场。我当时想：哇。这种感觉太棒了。这简直是极品。这真的是最棒的。你知道那种感觉吗？就好像你心里在想：哦，刚才好像产生了一种带电的火花。某种，
but maybe it ends up being a thing that cool guys bring up on a podcast years from now. So, yeah, at what point... So wait for those cool guys, I guess. Yeah, where are they? When do they join me? And we will be right back. And back to the show.
我不知道，也许什么都不是，但也许它最终会成为一个很酷的家伙们在多年后的播客节目里拿出来聊的话题。所以，是的，在哪个时刻……那就敬请期待那些酷家伙们吧。对，他们在哪？他们什么时候加入我？我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目。
At what point did you start thinking, God, I would love to parlay some of this, you know, great access and position in the community into producing as well because you're such an accomplished producer. Your company, Lucky Chad. Thank you.
你是在哪个时刻开始心想：天哪，我很想把这一切，你知道的，在业界获得的优质人脉和地位，顺便转化到制片领域里去，因为你是一位如此出色的制片人。你的公司叫“幸运查普”（Lucky Chaps）。谢谢。
Well, I told you was the first thing that we produced, well, it was actually the second movie we produced, but the first one that came out. So it was kind of kicked things off really nicely. We started talking about the production company in 2013, so the year after Waffle Wall Street. Okay. So after Wufel Wall Street, before it had come out,
嗯，我跟你说过这是我们制作的第一部作品，好吧，其实这是我们制作的第二部电影，但却是第一部上映的。所以它确实为我们的制片事业开了一个非常好的头。我们是在2013年开始讨论成立制片公司的，也就是《华尔街之狼》上映的第二年。好吧。所以是在《华尔街之狼》之后，在它上映之前，
I went off to Belgium to shoot this movie called Sweet Frances, which I've actually never seen. and I met my two producer partners, one of whom I'm now married to. So Josie and Tom was second and third AD on that job, and we all became friends on that job. Yeah, Wolf Wall Street wasn't out yet, so that must have been 20. Anyways, whatever, very early on. And that's when we talked about starting a production company,
我去了比利时拍摄一部名为《法式组曲》（Suite Française）的电影，这部电影我其实从来没看过。在那里我遇到了我的两个制片合伙人，其中一位现在成了我的丈夫。乔西（Josy）和汤姆（Tom）当时是那部戏的第二和第三副导演，我们都在那部戏里成为了朋友。是的，《华尔街之狼》当时还没上映，所以那大概是20世纪……不管怎样，反正很早就开始了。也就是在那时候，我们讨论了成立制片公司的事，
and we started the company the following year. And, yeah, so it's, yeah, we've had it for like 11 years now. I love that you work with your husband. I just think that's great. My wife and I are working together. a bit now and it's just it's just so i just love it it's oh you love it okay sorry i didn't know which way you're going to go with that yeah and the look on your face you got kind of lost a little now i if i i'd love to get my spouse to play golf too uh you you're you're tom can swing a golf club he has
我们在第二年正式成立了公司。所以，是的，我们已经经营11年了。我非常喜欢你和你的丈夫一起工作。我觉得这太棒了。我和我妻子现在也一起合作一点项目，这感觉，真的太棒了，我太喜欢了。哦，你很喜欢，对吧？抱歉，我不知道你刚刚是顺着这个话题往哪儿说。对，看你的表情，你刚才有点走神了。现在，如果，我真希望我配偶也能陪我打高尔夫。呃，汤姆会挥高尔夫球杆吗？他
tried to make me play golf so many times no don't bother i'm going to play with them he's he and are going to become big big golf buddies willie he's uh he's he's he's coming on up oh is that right yeah yeah Okay, oh good. Tom on the board. Are you all golfers together? Are you all going to be golf together? Yeah, yeah, we play at it. Yeah, I love it.
试图让我打过好多次高尔夫。不，别费劲了。我要和他们一起去打，他和我要成为非常非常要好的高尔夫球友了。真的吗？他，他，他，他正在上道呢。哦，是吗？对，对，对。好吧，哦太好了。汤姆也上场了。你们大家是一起打高尔夫吗？你们以后都会一起去打高尔夫吗？对，对，我们会一起玩。是的，我很喜欢。
Yeah, I mean, he's obsessed with golf. Like, I feel like every dude I know turned 30 and suddenly overnight was obsessed with golf. Like, I was like, I've never heard any of you talk about golf. Yeah. And they all seem to hate it and themselves so much, but want to do it all the time. It's such a weird. It seems to be a very toxic relationship. It is.
是的，我是说，他沉迷于高尔夫。我觉得我认识的所有男人一到30岁，突然之间在一夜之间就迷上了高尔夫。当时我想：我以前从来没听你们任何人聊过高尔夫。是的。而且他们看起来对这项运动以及对自己都恨之入骨，但又总是想去打。这太诡异了。这似乎是一种非常病态的关系。确实如此。
It is just incredibly challenging. thing that is hard to ignore. It perplexes me. It really does it. It really perplexes me. And I'm also like, you can love this thing without me. Like go, this can be a thing that I don't need to play golf. I'm going to set you up with my wife. It seems nice. That is so, yeah,
这简直是一项令人难以置信的具有挑战性、却又让人无法忽视的运动。这让我感到困惑。真的让我困惑。它真的让我困惑。而且我当时想：没有我，你也可以喜欢这玩意儿。去吧，这是一项不需要我陪着玩的高尔夫。我要把你介绍给我妻子。听起来不错。太对了，是的，
yeah, Amanda needs to hear that. Let's clip that for Amanda. I'm speaking of will you clip that for Amanda? Thank you. Margo, speaking of golf, I just had lunch two weeks ago, three weeks ago.
阿曼达（Amanda）需要听听这个。把这段剪下来发给阿曼达。说到这个，你能把这段剪辑发给阿曼达吗？谢谢。玛格特，说到高尔夫，我两周前、三周前刚吃过午饭。
On a golf, of course, with a non-crice. Oh, no way. Yeah, who is the real-life CEO of Mattel. This real-life CEO of Mattel. And we were talking about you, and we were talking about Barbie, of course. And I'm like, how did that count? And he's like, he told me, because he's such a great guy.
在一个高尔夫球场上，和一个非克里斯（non-crice）的人。哦，不会吧。是的，他就是美泰（Mattel）的现实生活中的CEO。美泰的现实生活中的CEO。我们当时在聊你，当然也在聊《芭比》（Barbie）。然后我说：这事是怎么谈成的？他告诉我，因为他是个超级好的人。
He's like, this is the pitch. Magro-Rabi, Barbie, that was the pitch. What's that got to do with golf? Really? No, because we were having lunch on the golf course. What golf course? Will? Which golf course was?
他说：这就是最初的推介（pitch）。玛格特·罗比，芭比，最初的推介就是这样。这跟高尔夫有什么关系？真的吗？不，因为我们当时是在高尔夫球场上吃午饭。哪个高尔夫球场？威尔？那是哪个球场？
I had. Do you remember that? When you called me, I was like, I'm going to come. I was about to say, do you want me to start rattling them off? I hate that I know them all, but. Because that's where he wanted to have lunch. Jason, why are you getting bogged down in the detail? I need to understand. How does Sean Hayes end up at Hillcrest? Oh, I got
我记得。当时你给我打电话，我说：我要去了。我正想说：你想让我把它们全念出来吗？我讨厌自己把这些全记住，但是……因为那是他想吃午饭的地方。杰森，你为什么非要纠结于这些细节？我得搞明白。肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）怎么会跑到山顶俱乐部（Hillcrest）去的？哦，我拿到了
a pass. What is with the look on your face? Why are you so mad at him? Who has lunch at Hillcrest unless you're making the time? Are you not allowed at Hillcrest? No, a friend of ours set us up as just to have lunch. You guys would have a good time, so we had a good time, and I talked to me. And he's Look at his face.
通行证。你那是什么表情？你为什么对他这么生气的样子？除非你在谈生意，否则谁会去山顶俱乐部吃午饭？你难道不被允许去山顶俱乐部吗？不，我们的一位朋友安排我们在那里吃午饭。你们会玩得很开心的，所以我们玩得很开心，我也和自己聊了聊。看他的表情。
Oh, yeah. People can only hear this. You can't see Jason's face right now. It is. Yeah, she's wonderful. It's gorgeous there. Yeah, it's hard to get out there. And you just thought you just have your sandwich out there, I guess.
哦，是的。听众只能听到声音。你现在看不到杰森的脸。太逗了。是的，她太棒了。那里美极了。是的，很难进去。我想你大概就是去那里吃个三明治吧。
He's so mad. Anyway, Enon spoke very highly of you. He's such a good guy. And when he told me, the pitch was just you and Barbie. That's where it started. And then everything else just kind of snowballed from there, which is incredible. So we're going to fly over Quentin.
他气坏了。不管怎样，伊农（Ynon）对你的评价极高。他是个极好的人。当他告诉我，最初的创意推介就只有你和芭比时。一切就是从那里开始的。然后其他所有事情就像滚雪球一样接踵而至，这太不可思议了。所以我们要飞过去找昆汀·
Tarantino and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood and we're going to go right to Barbie. No. Right to Barbie. No, wait. We don't have to talk about Barbie. I just thought, what a coincidence you're here and I had lunch with Inan and it was very... No, he made the golf match and that's fair enough. That's a very good...
塔伦蒂诺（Quentin Tarantino）拍《好莱坞往事》（Once Upon a Time in Hollywood），然后直接转到《芭比》。不对。直接拍《芭比》。不，等等。我们其实不用聊《芭比》。我只是觉得，你在这里出现真是太巧了，而且我和伊农吃过午饭，而且非常……不，是他安排的高尔夫球局，那倒也合情合理。这是一个非常好的……
We will allow. Once Upon a Time in Hollywood. Once Upon a Time in Hollywood What a film. What a film. What a film. Now, is being on a set with Quentin as exciting as it seems? Yes. Yes, yes, yes. It is everything.
我们允许这样做。《好莱坞往事》。《好莱坞往事》！多么棒的一部电影。多棒的电影啊。多棒的电影啊。那么，在片场和昆汀合作，真的有看起来那么激动人心吗？是的。是的，是的，是的。一切都是真的。
I'm a huge Tarantino fan. and it is, so I've read, like, you know, all the folklore around making a movie with Quentin. Like, he doesn't allow our phones on set and da-da-da-da-da-da. It's all true, and it's everything you'd want it to be and more. It was just the best. That's an awesome, awesome, awesome film. I so love that.
我是昆汀的超级粉丝。而且正如我所读到的，你知道，所有关于和昆汀拍电影的民间传说……比如他不允许我们在片场带手机等等等等。全都是真的，而且这完全符合你所期望的一切，甚至有过之而无不及。简直是棒极了。那真是一部了不起、了不起、了不起的电影。我太喜欢了。
I still can't believe. You're like, remember when that first, I think was it Cannes where it first was shown? Yeah. And he made some declaration to the press in like a really cool way saying, Listen, I know some directors say, you know, please watch the spoilers when you write these reviews and everything, but he like made this like real, like, but I'm serious.
我到现在还是不敢相信。就像你还记得当时，第一次，我想是戛纳电影节吧，电影首次上映的时候？是的。他以一种非常酷的方式向媒体发表了一份声明，大致意思是：听着，我知道有些导演会说，请大家在写影评时注意剧透之类的，但他发表了这样一份动真格的声明：但我说真的。
Please try not to reveal the ending to everyone, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I remember reading that and going, okay, this is never going to last. Somebody is going to spread. But I remember that I made it to watching the movie, which was months later, without ever hearing what the ending was about, and was so excited by the reveal of what that ending was
请尽量不要向所有人透露结局，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我记得当时读到那个声明时心想：好吧，这绝对维持不了多久。肯定会有人把结局泄露出去的。但我记得我直到几个月后去看这部电影时，从没有听到任何人剧透结局是什么，当最终揭晓那个结局时，我感到无比兴奋，
and fucking love the way that thing already. wraps up. I just, what a film. I know. Isn't that amazing that no one spoiled that? Yeah, I couldn't do. That was like a separate part of the script that only a few of us were allowed to even have. And so like the crew didn't have it. Like it was kept so under lock and key because you really wanted to preserve that. And it's so impactful when you get to the end of the movie and you're like,
而且超级喜欢电影收尾的方式。我只是觉得，多棒的电影啊。我知道。没有人剧透，这难道不是很神奇吗？是的，我做不到。那是剧本中一个独立的部分，只有我们极少数人被允许拥有。所以剧组人员都没有拿到。保密工作做得极其严密，因为你真的想保留那种悬念。当你看到电影结尾时，那种冲击力太强了，你会想：
holy shit, Sharon's live. Wait, this means Sharon Tate lives. Like this is such a great alternate universe. but I you know knowing how secret he wanted everything to be I I never breathed a word of how it ended and at can I brought my mom to watch the movie and I asked her afterwards you know we're all clapping and I was like what did you think and she she goes honestly I have been dreading watching this movie because I did not want to see my daughter be killed in the way in that way like in a no Tarantino movies are violent and like she's like I know and I didn't want to you know burst your bubble because you know, clue was so excited about this, but like, I've been dreading it. And she was like, I didn't know. Anyway, so Quentin was looking at me.
天呐，莎朗（Sharon）还活着。等等，这意味着莎朗·塔特活下来了。这是一个多么棒的平行宇宙啊。但我，你知道的，既然知道他对保密的要求有多高，我连一个字都没有透露过电影是怎么收尾的。在戛纳，我带我妈妈去看这部电影，散场后我问她，你知道的，当时大家都在鼓掌，我问她：你觉得怎么样？她回答说：老实说，我一直非常害怕看这部电影，因为我一点也不想看到我女儿以那种方式，在那种情况下被杀害。你知道的，昆汀的电影都很暴力，她接着说：我知道，我不想扫你的兴，因为你之前对这部电影兴奋得不得了，但我一直提心吊胆的。然后她说：我没想到……总之，昆汀当时正看着我。
He's like, he's like, did your mom like the movie? And I was like, oh, she was upset because she thought she was about to see me die. And he's like, you didn't tell your mom, you don't die? And I was like, no, you told me not to tell anyone the ending of this movie. I didn't tell anyone. He was like, well, at least tell your mom. And I was like, I didn't tell my husband. I didn't tell my mom.
他说：他问：你妈妈喜欢这部电影吗？我回答说：哦，她一开始很难过，因为她以为她马上要看到我死在银幕上了。他说：你没告诉你妈妈你没死吗？我说：没有，你告诉过我不要把电影结局告诉任何人。我谁也没告诉。他说：好吧，至少该告诉你妈妈吧。我说：我连我丈夫都没告诉。我连我妈妈也没告诉。
I didn't tell anyone how this movie ended. So, yeah, we were all in keeping it, keeping it secret. All right. All right. So, all right. the behemoth of Barbie, it comes into your world in sort of a typical way, like kind of through the regular sort of channels, or is it something that you pursued? No, not really.
我没有把这部电影的结局告诉任何人。所以，是的，我们所有人都死守秘密，保密到底。好啦。好啦。那么，接下来。庞然大物《芭比》进入你的世界，是以一种典型的方式，比如通过常规渠道，还是你自己主动去争取来的？不，其实不是。
I mean, no, we pursued it. Like, as the company, as Lucky Chap, we went after it. We knew that the agreement over, you know, it was set up already over at Sony. There had been versions of it, et cetera, et cetera. And then their time was kind of up. Deadline Hollywood, don't worry, he knows the deal of it. Hey, yeah, Amy Schumer, you know, blah, blah, blah. Yeah.
我是说，不，是我们主动争取的。作为制片公司，作为“幸运查普”，我们主动出击。我们知道关于这个项目的版权协议，你知道的，它当时已经在索尼（Sony）立项了。之前有过各种版本，诸如此类。然后他们的版权期快到了。好莱坞报道（Deadline Hollywood），别担心，他很清楚这其中的门道。嘿，是的，艾 Amy Schumer，你知道的，巴拉巴拉。对。
There was a tournament for a while. Sure. He knows. He knows the deal. A bunch of money against it. And then... Exactly.
中间确实有一段时间的角逐。当然。他懂。他懂内幕。有一大笔资金在竞争这个项目。然后……没错。
But there was, you know, like, they had to re-up the deal sort of thing. And so that was the opportunity to get in there and say, can we take it? And so we kind of made our pitch to Enon, Sean's friend. So we made the pitch to him. We're like, let Lucky Chap produce this. Let us have this.
但是，你知道的，他们必须续签协议。所以这就是切入并争取的机会：我们能接手吗？于是我们向肖恩的朋友伊农进行了推介。我们向他做了推介。我们说：让“幸运查普”来制作这个。把这个项目交给我们吧。
We'll set it up at Warner Brothers. So there's no chain of titles issue with whatever they've previously developed. This is before Greta and Noah? Yeah. Before Greta and Noah, so it was just us. So then your take then was, sorry to interrupt, but your take, because the reason it's sort of, it is relevant and interesting that it had this life beforehand was that obviously the version at Sony with Amy would be wildly different than what you guys were doing.
我们会把它放在华纳兄弟（Warner Brothers）推进，这样就不会有之前开发阶段产生的任何版权链问题。这是在 Greta（导演格蕾塔·葛韦格）和 Noah（编剧诺亚·鲍姆巴赫）加入之前？对。在格蕾塔和诺亚加入之前，所以当时只有我们。那么你们当时的想法是——抱歉打断一下——你们的想法是，之所以它有前期的开发历史这一点既相关又有趣，是因为索尼时期艾米·舒默的那个版本显然会跟你们后来做的版本大相径庭。
Because think about it, like, that's what the, Mattel, you know, they've got all this great, you know, IP, they're just like games or in this, you know, an action figure. And it's like, how do you come up with a movie about that? You have to have a take. Like, what's the angle going to be? What's it going to be about? And with Barbie, it's so loaded to like, you can have a cultural reference to it, some sort of societal comment, all this stuff.
因为你想想看，美泰公司拥有所有这些优秀的IP，它们只是一些游戏或者动作玩偶。问题是：你怎么能根据这些拍出一部电影？你必须有一个独特的视角（take）。角度会是什么？它究竟要讲什么？对于《芭比》来说，它蕴含的文化符号太丰富了，你可以做出各种文化参考、社会评论之类的东西。
So what was your take? So this is before you had the writer and the director. Did you have a clear idea about what you wanted to say with this? and then that informed where you looked for a writer and a director? To be honest, the first hurdle was getting them to let us have it. Right. And so really those first conversations were about making sure Enon and Mattel knew that we would protect the brand and take care of it, but also do something meaningful with it.
所以你们的构思/切入点是什么？是在找到编剧和导演之前就想好的吗？老实说，第一个难关是让他们把版权交给我们。没错。所以最初的那些对话，实际上全都是为了让伊农和美泰确信：我们会保护这个品牌并爱护它，但同时也会用它做出一些有意义的内容。
And we were quite honest in that first meeting of like, if we're doing a Barbie movie, we're going to be saying something and it has to be culturally relevant. And this has to be elevated and cinematic. and all the things. Like it's, but do understand, like, we're going to be making comments with the movie sort of thing. So obviously we'll do that with someone who's very smart. Like, I did pitch Greta in the meeting.
我们在第一次会议上就很坦诚地表示，如果要拍芭影业，我们就得表达一些观点，而且必须具有文化相关性。这必须是有提升感的、有电影质感的，以及方方面面都要到位。就像是，但你要明白，我们拍这部电影是会带有某种评论色彩的。所以很显然，我们会找一个非常聪明的人来做这事。我在会上确实向大家推荐了格蕾塔。
I was like, you know, like a Greta Girlwig. Yeah, so smart. Who I had spoken to previously about other films and stuff. And she, I think at the time was filming little women, but she had done Lady Bird. Anyways. And so, yeah, so first, step one really was just like letting them know that we would, we understood how important this property is to them that we would be good partners to them
我当时就说，你知道的，就像“格蕾塔女孩维格”。没错，太聪明了。我之前曾与其他电影相关事宜跟她聊过。她当时好像正在拍《小妇人》，但她之前拍过《伯德小姐》。总之。所以，是的，第一步其实就是让他们知道，我们深知这个IP对他们有多重要，我们会成为他们优秀的合作伙伴
and then also like, yeah, then it was setting it up the studio and then it was going after Greta and being like, do you want to do a Barbie movie? And then it was about what her take was really. It was never me being like, I have a take, do you want to do this? It was like, I trust you to have something.
然后还有，是的，接下来就是去找制片厂立项，接着去找格蕾塔，问她：“你想拍一部芭比电影吗？”然后关键就在于她的构思究竟是什么。我从来不是那种说“我有个构思，你想拍吗”的人。我的态度是：“我相信你会有自己的想法，
I bet you have something to say, what would you want to say with a Barbie movie with me? And then it kind of went from there. And her and Noah, where their writing process is fascinating, but they don't really plot out. They don't outline a whole thing and then send in an outline,
我打赌你一定有话要说，拍一部芭比电影你想表达什么？”然后事情就顺理成章地发展下去了。她和诺亚的剧作过程非常迷人，但他们其实并不怎么做大纲。他们不会先写出一个完整的大纲然后交上去，
you know what you're going to get. They don't really know how it's going to end. They write as they go. They write themselves in corners. They write themselves out of corners. So getting the studio and Mattel to sign off on the movie and get them paid to commence because then it was COVID too, and I was like, they need to be writing right now.
你知道会是什么结果。他们其实并不知道故事会怎么结束。他们边写边构思。他们把自己写进死胡同里，然后再自己从死胡同里走出来。所以要让制片厂和美泰公司对电影签字画押，并开始支付薪酬——因为当时也正赶上疫情，我就觉得，他们必须马上开始写作。
And they were like, well, what's the movie? Yeah. And everyone's feeling very protective over this thing and want to know what it is and what they're paying for and all that kind of stuff. Yeah, it was kind of, yeah, I think it was probably the best bit of producing
而他们的反应是：“好吧，那这电影到底是讲什么的？”是的。每个人对这个项目都充满了保护欲，想知道它到底是什么、他们花钱买的到底是什么，诸如此类的事情。是的，这差不多可以说是，我觉得这可能算得上我们做过最好的制片工作了，
we ever did was getting, getting that whole, all those deals, treatment deals, you know, no approval over the script, but approval over the treatment, like all this kind of stuff so that they... You got to convince a lot of people that sort of like, just trust us,
就是搞定那些所有的交易、剧本大纲交易，你知道的，对剧本本身没有审批权，但对大纲有审批权，所有诸如此类的事情，好让他们……你得说服很多人去达成一种态度，那就是：相信我们，
just trust us. It was completely just trust us and also leave them alone. Like you cannot. They're not going to get on the phone with you and tell that they're not going to pitch you. Like, we have to leave them It says a lot about Mattel and Warner Brothers for taking that risk and, like, that's a lot of courage.
只管相信我们。完全就是“相信我们”，然后别去打扰他们。因为你不可能。他们不会跟你通电话，也不会向你阐述构思——我们必须放手让他们去创作。美泰和华纳兄弟愿意承担这种风险，这说明了很多问题，也需要极大的勇气。
It's so great that it worked out so well for them. I've been huge. I mean, I asked the dumb questions if you haven't picked up on that yet. So will there be a sequel? Well, there could be. Because, I mean, why wouldn't there be? But Greta's been, I mean, I'm open. There's no plans at the moment, but I'm open to it.
事情对他们来说能有这么好的结果，真是太棒了。我的影响太大了。我是说，如果你还没看出来的话，我总是会问一些愚蠢的问题。那么，会有续集吗？嗯，有可能是有的。因为，我是说，为什么不呢？不过格蕾塔一直在——我是说，我很持开放态度。目前还没有计划，但我对这事持开放态度。
I'm open to anything with Greta, to be honest. But she's been doing Narnia for ages. I can't wait for that. Cool. Yeah, she's been like really intensely into it. Do you love them too? Have you read, do you? Have you ever read a book series called The Magicians?
说实话，对于和格蕾塔合作的任何事我都持开放态度。但她一直在筹备《纳尼亚传奇》好一阵子了。我等不及想看那个了。太酷了。是的，她一直非常投入地在弄这个。你也喜欢它们吗？你读过、你读过吗？你读过一套叫《魔法师》的书吗？
It's like this like grown up dark Narnia version of Narnia. No, but I will. It's so good. Yeah. Tell us Sean what channel it's on and he'll watch it for fun. Books, they're books. Wait, the magicians. Oh, wow.
它有点像成年暗黑版的《纳尼亚传奇》。没有，但我会去读的。太棒了。是的。肖恩，告诉我们它在哪个频道播，他会为了好玩去看。书，那是书。等等，《魔法师》。哦，哇。
Is it the same tone as the Narnia books and stuff? Well, it just, it's like, I love fantasy books. I read a lot of fantasy, and it's a really good. Oh, good. Well, then check them out. I mean, it's just, but it's very much seeped in like Narni allure, which I, which I... Why don't you, why isn't your production company option those books?
它的基调跟《纳尼亚传奇》那些书一样吗？嗯，它就是，我喜欢奇幻书。我读了很多奇幻小说，这是一本非常棒的。哦，那很好。好吧，那就去看看吧。我是说，它里面确实有很多纳尼亚式的韵味，而我，而我……你为什么不，你的制片公司为什么不买下那些书的影视改编权呢？
Well, actually, if I'm going to option anything, I read a lot of, like I said, a lot of fantasy, but I read a lot of romantasy books as well. So, I think since our brand is very, like, female-focused, there's some other romanticcy books that I'd rather go after. Well, that's getting us right. Right to Wuthering Heights. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，其实如果要买改编权的话，我读过很多——就像我说的，很多奇幻小说，但我也读了很多浪漫奇幻（romantasy）小说。所以，我觉得既然我们的品牌定位非常偏向女性受众，还有其他一些浪漫奇幻小说是我更想去争取的。哦，这正合我们意。直接切入《呼啸山庄》。对。是的。
With the divine Jacob Allorty. What a nice guy. Just met him the other day. What a really, really good. By the way, sidebar, we just had Charlie XX on. And she did the music for it. She did a whole album. She did an entire album.
由神仙般的雅各布·埃洛迪出演。多好的一个小伙子。前几天刚见过他。真是个非常、非常好的人。顺便插一句，我们刚刚请到了Charli XCX做嘉宾。她为这部电影创作了音乐。她做了一整张专辑。她做了一整张专辑。
Yeah. Her whole album is called Warwick Heights. Yeah. And another collaboration with you and Emerald Fennell. Yeah. Third film together. So we produced Promising Young Woman, then Solt. and now this is her third film and our third film together.
是的。她整张专辑都叫《沃里克高地》。是的。这也是你和埃默拉尔德·芬内尔的又一次合作。是的。这是第三次合作拍电影了。我们先是制作了《前程似锦的年轻女子》，然后是《萨尔本》，而现在这是她的第三部电影，也是我们合作的第三部电影。
She's only been in the States for 16 years. I know. Look at all of this. It's amazing. It's amazing. It's amazing. So Wuthering Heights, you're a big softy with the romance stuff. Was this, did this come out?
她来美国才16年。我知道。看看这一切。这太惊人了。这太惊人了。这太惊人了。所以说到《呼啸山庄》，你在浪漫题材上其实是个大感性的人。这个，这个是怎么出来的？
It's the ultimate romance. It's the ultimate, yeah. It's much like your relationship with golf. It's like you just can't, you can't help it even though it's destroying you on some level. Thank you for putting it in a context that we can understand. Thank you. I'm currently in a divorce with golf right now. I'm working.
这是终极的浪漫。这绝对是，是的。这就很像你和高尔夫的关系。就是那种你根本无法自拔，哪怕它在某种程度上正在毁掉你。谢谢你把它放在一个我们能理解的语境里。谢谢。我目前正处于和高尔夫离婚的阶段。我在工作。
I'm going to be dedicated to my life right now. But okay, so now you've seen the film. Many times, yes. Do you cry every time? Every time. I have never watched it and not cried. I love you. And I, like, it's, yeah, it's so good.
我现在要全身心投入到生活中。不过，好吧，现在你已经看过这部电影了。看过很多遍了，是的。你每次都会哭吗？每次都哭。我从来没有看过它而不哭的。我太喜欢了。而且我，就觉得，是的，太棒了。
I mean, it's just, I'm so excited that everyone's about to see it because it's incredible. It's coming out on Valentine's Day, right? Perfect Valentine's, Galentine's plan. Yeah, if you don't have plans. Friday, February 13th. It did come out three days ago. Yeah, February 16th today, you guys.
我是说，我太激动了，因为每个人都快要看到它了，它真的是不可思议。它将在情人节上映，对吧？完美的情人节、闺蜜节计划。是的，如果你还没有安排的话。2月13日，星期五。它确实是三天前上映的。对，今天是2月16日，各位。
It's out now. It's February 16th today? Okay, guys, if you haven't seen it yet, I apologize. Okay, so does that mean, is it the Monday? Is it the public holiday today? Okay, you've got time. Go to the movies right now. Even as I slap this laptop down, I'm going. Yes, it's President's Day weekend.
现在已经上映了。今天是2月16日吗？好吧，各位，如果你还没看过，我向你们道歉。好吧，所以这意思，今天是周一吗？今天是法定假日吗？好吧，你们还有时间。现在就去看电影吧。甚至当我把这台笔记本电脑啪地合上时，我就要去了。对，这周末是总统日。
It's President's Day. It's Valentine's. It's a big weekend. Go out see it today. Today, go see it. It's just an incredible film. Like, it really, really is. And it's so moving and evocative and provocative and provocative at times.
这是总统日。这是情人节。这是个重大的周末。今天就出门去看吧。今天，去看电影吧。这真是一部不可思议的电影。我是说，真的非常、非常棒。而且它非常感人、动人、富有诗意，有时还带着挑衅意味。
But it's, I really think it's going to make people feel. And then what about, did you, because it's chemistry with an actor is so vital. especially I would imagine if you're doing some sort of a romantic film with someone. Did you do some research about, like did you call around with people that, or did you know Jacob from Saltburn? So yeah, I knew him in a kind of like a producer-actor dynamic from Saltburn and always thought he was so lovely and so talented. I mean, I was the very, when I read Saltburn, it's the first thing I said.
但我真的觉得它会触动人们的心弦。还有，你有没有——因为与演员的化学反应至关重要，特别是我想象中如果你和某人一起拍某种浪漫电影的话。你有没有做过什么调查，比如跟别人打听过，或者你在《萨尔本》的时候就认识雅各布了？所以，是的，我从《萨尔本》时起就以制片人与演员的动态关系认识他了，并且一直觉得他非常可爱，也非常有才华。我是说，当我在读《萨尔本》的剧本时，这是我说的第一句话。
I was like, Jacob Allorty should play Felix. I was such a fan of his work from Euphoria. back then. So then you knew you two would get along. Well, we're also from, he's from Brisbane and I'm from the Gold Coast. So we're from like an hour away from each other. We're both Queenslanders. So I don't know.
我当时就说：“雅各布·埃洛迪应该扮演菲利克斯。”早在那个时候，我就已经是他在《亢奋》中的表演的超级粉丝了。所以当时你就知道你们俩会合得来。嗯，我们还都是从——他是布里斯班人，我是黄金海岸人。所以我们老家离大概就一个小时的车程。我们都是昆士兰人。所以，我不知道。
I had a feeling I was like, we're both Queenslanders. We'll be best names. It'll be great. Yeah. He's also, he's just so good. And I think what really helps is we approach our work in a very similar way. And I think that really helped. And I think when it comes to chemistry.
我有一种预感，心想我们都是昆士兰人。我们会成为最要好的朋友。这会很棒的。是的。而且他，他就是这么棒。我觉得真正有帮助的是，我们对待工作的方式非常相似，我觉得这真的很有帮助。而且我认为当谈到化学反应时。
And how is that? Well, we're both very, we're both very, very, very, like, we take it very seriously. We do a lot of prep. We do a lot of work, you know, like, we're both on set with, like, notebooks and writing and notes, and, you know, like, we're, you know. Yeah, so I don't know. And we were kind of, to be honest, I think we were kind of set up for success
那是怎样的？嗯，我们俩都非常、非常、非常——我们对工作极其认真。我们做了大量的准备工作。我们做了大量的工作，你知道的，比如我们俩在片场都拿着笔记本、写写记记，做笔记，你知道的，就是这样。是的，所以，我不知道。而且说实话，我觉得我们可以说是注定会成功，
because the script was so good. I mean, and Emerald's an Oscar-winning screenplay writer. The script was unbelievable. We had, you know, then the source material has been, you know, adored for almost 200 years. Then you've got Emerald's take of it, and her writing's incredible, and she's plucking out lines and stuff in the book, too.
因为剧本太棒了。我是说，而且埃默拉尔德是一位获得过奥斯卡奖的编剧。剧本简直难以置信。我们拥有，你知道的，原作已经被喜爱了近两百年。然后你再加上埃默拉尔德对它的独特诠释，她的写作极其出色，她甚至还挑出了书中一些精彩的台词之类的。
And then you've got, you know, some of the industry's best designers, cinematographers, production designers, costume design, all that kind of thing. You know, we had all the elements. Where'd you shoot at? We shot in London, and then on the Moors in Yorkshire. So that's so beautiful. And so, yeah, I mean, we kind of had it all there,
然后你还拥有，你知道的，行业内最顶尖的设计师、摄影师、制片设计师、服装设计师，所有这些类似的人才。你知道，我们具备了所有的要素。你们在哪里拍摄的？我们在伦敦拍的，然后是在约克郡的荒原上。那真是太美了。所以，是的，我是说，我们基本上把一切都准备就绪了，
and it all came together. and we get along and it was, yeah, it was just great. It was so great. I can't wait. I know. I'm so excited to do that together. I mean, you're so, I'm so taken with you, you seem so charming and warm, as I said, at the beginning. And grounding.
一切都水到渠成。而且我们相处得很好，所以，是的，真的很棒。太棒了。我等不及了。我知道。我太兴奋能一起做这件事了。我是说，你太——我太为你着迷了，正如我一开始所说的那样，你看起来那么迷人、那么温暖。而且很有落地感。
You're just such a pleasure. You're just a farm girl. Yeah. That's all. What knocks you off, what knocks you off balance? When are you not charming? When are you not? Like, what would Tom?
你真是个令人愉快的人。你不过是个农场女孩罢了。是的。仅此而已。什么事会让你方寸大乱？什么事会让你失去平衡？你什么时候会不迷人？你什么时候不会？比如说汤姆会说些什么？
What would Tom tell us is really your kryptonite? Yeah. When I'm hungry. Oh, yeah. You don't, I'm not charming when I'm hungry. And I'm almost always hungry, to be honest. I get angry. Yeah.
汤姆会告诉我们，你的致命弱点到底是什么？是的。当我饿的时候。哦，对。你不会——我饿的时候一点也不迷人。而且老实说，我几乎总是处于饥饿状态。我会生气的。是的。
He calls me Dragoons sometimes. He's like, he knows, he's like, I need to feed the dragon. Does he cook for you? Yeah, he's an amazing cook. Is he? Yeah, he could be a chef. He's so good. Really?
他有时叫我“龙骑士”。他懂的，他会说：“我得喂喂这条龙了。”他会给你做饭吗？是的，他是个了不起的厨师。是吗？是的，他完全可以去当大厨。他太棒了。真的吗？
I want to know how to cook. God damn it. You guys will be golf besties. You can, oh, don't even get me. You think he loves golf. You should start cooking for you, J.B. You should see what he does with the big green egg. He's, oh, my God.
我想学怎么做饭。该死。你们俩会成为高尔夫好基友的。你可以——哦，别跟我提这个。你以为他爱打高尔夫。你应该开始为自己做饭，J.B.。你真该看看他用那个“大绿蛋”烧烤炉做出来的东西。他，哦，天哪。
I'll steal him. It's his other mistress. I'll just take him. Yeah, take him. Take him. He'll love it. What's your go-to? What's your go-to meal?
我会把他抢走。那是他的另一个情妇。我直接把他带走。是的，带走他。带走他。他会喜欢的。你最拿手的是什么？你最拿手的饭菜是什么？
If you're like, honey, I'm really hungry. I fix my favorite thing. You know what it is. What is it? To be honest, he can, he can cook a steak better than any restaurant can. Like his steak, like, it's almost ruined getting a steak. Oh, I don't know what he does, but it's magic. He does that in the green egg?
如果你说：“亲爱的，我真的饿了。给我做我最爱吃的那样东西。”你知道那是什么。那是什么？说实话，他烤牛排的手艺比任何餐馆都要好。就像他的牛排，吃过之后去外面吃牛排都觉得索然无味了。哦，我不知道他是怎么做到的，但这简直是魔法。他用那个大绿蛋烤炉做那个吗？
He'll do it. Oh, no, I think he does a bit of a, I think he does a little. slash reverse sear in a skillet pan situation for his steaks, but he can do it on the green egg as well. Somebody made me a hamburger once and put an egg on it with blue cheese. I was like, no thanks. No, that's cool. That's cool.
他会用那个。哦，不，我觉得他大概会——我觉得他做牛排时会在平底煎锅里做一下生煎加反向煎烤的组合，不过他在大绿蛋烤炉上也能做。曾经有人给我做过一个汉堡，上面放了一个鸡蛋和蓝纹奶酪。我当时想：不用了，谢谢。不，这挺酷的。这挺酷的。
Save it for the book. Marko, yeah, this is Margo's time, Sean. Thank you so much for joining us today. I know you've got a lot of press in front of you. I appreciate all the time. Yeah. And best of luck with the film. We're going to watch it this afternoon.
留着写进书里吧。玛戈，是的，这是玛戈的时间，肖恩。非常感谢你今天能来。我知道你接下来还有很多宣传通告要赶。我很感激你抽出时间。是的。祝你的电影大吉大利。我们今天下午就要去看了。
We're all going to go to Century City. Are you actually? Yeah. We're going to go to Century City this afternoon. Oh, yeah. Oh, yes, of course. It's the 16th today. Yes, go watch it. Go watch it together.
我们全都要去世纪城。你们真的要去吗？对。我们今天下午要去世纪城。哦，对。哦，对，没错。今天是16号。没错，去吧。去看吧。你们一起去看。
You're our core demographics. So enjoy, tell me with you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So great meeting you. Thank you for doing this. No, thank you. Good luck with the play as well, Sean. Oh, thank you, honey.
你们是我们核心的目标受众。所以尽情享受吧，很高兴认识你。对，对，对。很高兴见到你。谢谢你做这一切。不，谢谢你。也祝你的舞台剧演出顺利，肖恩。哦，谢谢你，亲爱的。
Thank you so much. So sweet of you. All right, well, hopefully we'll see you soon. See you soon. Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye. Oh, I mean, I need a shower, all the negativity and that's just the chump.
非常感谢。你太贴好了。好吧，希望我们不久后能再见。回头见。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜。哦，我是说，我需要洗个澡，所有的负能量——而这仅仅是个开始。
I know. I mean, she is something else, man. I mean, what an angel. I mean, bam, bam, bam, bam, movie, big movie, big movie, big movie, big movie. I mean, she's, and she just got here like five minutes ago. And when she said she was on Pan Am, I felt like that was like five years ago, what was, like 15 years ago?
我知道。我是说，她真是不一般啊，老兄。我是说，简直是个天使。我是说，一部接一部，电影、大电影、大电影、大电影、大电影。我是说，她，而且她才刚来这里大约五分钟。当她说她演过《泛美航空》时，我觉得那是大概五年前的事了，其实是什么，大概15年前？
But if you just look at like, she just so hit the ground running, coming here. You know what I mean? And just doing quality things after quality things, always really good in everything she does. And I think the thing, what's almost impossible to get my head around is, Sean,
但如果你看看她是怎么一到这里就迅速打开局面的。你知道我的意思吗？一部接一部地拍出高质量的作品，在她所做的每一件事里都表现得非常出色。我觉得最让人难以置信、脑回路转不过弯来的是，肖恩，
you parking at Hillcrest and then you go over to the patio to have lunch? Like what are you indoors? What is going on? How did you get in there? Wait. You got there. Jason will take this to the, for the rest of those days. But wait.
你把车停在希尔克雷斯特（Hillcrest），然后走到露台上去吃午饭？你到底是怎么进到室内去的？这到底是怎么回事？你是怎么混进去的？等等。你居然进去了。杰森会把这事拿出来说好几天。但等等。
You ended up at Hillcrest Country Club. I can play there, but as a guest. Okay, so why? Is it hard to get in? I'm not, I'm not like, I can't call in and have a fucking lunch date there. I'm not a member. So you have to be a member to have lunch there. So mad.
你最后居然去了希尔克雷斯特乡村俱乐部。我可以在那里打球，但只能作为嘉宾。好吧，那为什么？那里很难进去吗？我不是，我不是那种——我不能直接打电话过去预约并在那里吃个商务午餐。我又不是会员。所以你必须是会员才能在那里吃午饭。太疯狂了。
Was the Mattel guy a member there? His name is Enon. No, a friend of ours was a mutual friend of us. No, not two fucking non-members having a business meeting. Unbelievable. All right, getting back into it. This woman, an incredible act.
那个美泰的家伙是那里的会员吗？他叫伊农。不是，我们的一个朋友是我们的共同好友。不对，两个根本不是会员的人居然在那里开商务会议？简直难以置信。好了，言归正传。这位女士，一个了不起的演员，
incredible producer I think will just be at the tip top of our profession for a very, very long time as she is now. Talented, beautiful, smart, all those things. Oh, you have something you want to say, Sean. Yeah, I do just really quick. Out of all the movies that I would have ever guessed
一个了不起的制片人，我觉得在很长很长的一段时间里，她都将处于她这个行业的绝对巅峰，正如她现在这样。有才华、美丽、聪明，具备所有这些优点。哦，你有话要说，肖恩。是的，我确实有，就简短说一句。在我猜测可能拍成电影的所有电影中——在她简历上的所有电影里，依然在热映中。在她简历上的所有电影中，有哪部票房能超过十亿美元的，我绝对不会猜到会是这部。
would make out of all of her movies on her resume still rolling. All of her movies on a resume that would have made over a billion dollars, I would have never guessed it would have been. Bar-bye. Bar-bye. I can't believe this.
芭比。芭比。我简直不敢相信这个。
Let me explain to you what the buy thing is. Wait, at least go, at least go buy, Tanya. Oh, shit, that's better. I just don't think you can, you can't make up a word for it to fit the buy. You have to actually find a legitimate buy-bye-bye-bye. Bar-bye. Bye-bye. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by,
让我向你解释一下这个“芭比”梗是怎么回事。等等，至少去买，至少去买杯咖啡，谭娅。哦，shit，那样更好。我只是觉得你不能为了押韵去硬造一个词来凑数。你必须真正找到一个合法的词。芭比。拜拜。SmartLess由Bob Armsurf、Bennett Barbico和Michael Grant Terry百分之百有机且手工打造。SmartLess。这期节目还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Bob Armjurf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
鲍勃·阿尔姆朱夫、本尼特·巴尔比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里。《Smartless》。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。